on the 13th of October 1989 the town of
Danner Wisconsin was shaken by a seismic
event unlike anything they'd ever
experienced this might have been written
off as an earthquake were it not for one
disturbing Factor the ground shaking
event was accompanied by a huge Spike of
radioactivity with the strange
phenomenon happening a month before the
Berlin Wall was torn down during a
period of the Cold War that historians
call the year of Crisis it's easy to
understand why the people of manner
immediately assumed the worst but the
huge eruption they felt wasn't the
result of a nuclear bomb going off the
SCP Foundation was alerted to the event
in Danner when they picked up a series
of radio Transmissions coming from just
outside the town when they arrived they
found something incredible like
something out of a sci-fi movie standing
at the quake's epicenter was a creature
that looked to be from another world
standing 2 m tall and weighing almost
300 kg the being was green and brown in
color with a bulky humanoid body its
head was a different story though and
resembled a gigantic housefly with a
prosus and huge stereoscopic eyes
surprisingly the strange creature did
not immediately go on a rampage instead
the being designated SCP
2273 appeared to be exhausted injured
and extremely malnourished it offered no
resistance at all to the foundation
containment team and it was taken to
site 17 without conflict while the SCP
Foundation is no stranger to visitors
from other worlds there was something
especially unusual about this supposed
alien Invader the doctors who examined
the creature and treated its injuries
found an appendage that seemed to
function as an organic radio transmitter
and large open wounds on its shoulder
blades and forearms where further
appendages had been ripped off
additionally while its insect-like
exoskeleton was mostly a uniform green
and brown pattern the creatures upper
arms and torso were dotted with a
variety of scars and markings that on
closer inspection looked like military
badges was this some kind of wounded
Intergalactic soldier who had been
stranded on Earth if it was then how
were the organic badges on this aliens
exoskeleton a near perfect match to
military badges worn by soldiers in the
Soviet Union even if they did reference
a unit that didn't officially exist
within the Soviet Army the scientists
were sure this alien wasn't an alien at
all underneath its exoskeleton was a
nonanomalous human being if that was
true then this was even more terrifying
than an extraterrestrial visitor the
scientists were sure that the USSR had
developed a new kind of organic armor
and this anomaly showing up in Wisconsin
was the result of a test on us soil that
had gone wrong if that was the case then
there was no telling how many more of
these exoskeletons were out there and
would need to be contained the
foundation had to act quickly and find
out more while SCP 2273 was recovering
they called in Dr Friedrich an on-site
psychologist who could speak several
languages including Russian Dr Friedrich
would be tasked with interrogating the
SCP on his Origins and the nature of the
suit the interview was conducted via AM
radio from a separate observation
chamber as the biological transmitter
seemed to be SCP 2273 is only method of
communication the interview began with
Dr Frederick's speaking to SCP 2273 in
Russian only for 2273 to respond that Dr
Frederick's accent was atrocious and
requesting he used German instead SCP
2273 who according to the organic
military patches on his body was named
Major Alexi bellatv initially resisted
being interviewed he believed that he
was a prisoner of war being held by the
American Military according to him he
had been in the middle of battle and
that the Americans had killed his man
and left him for dead dead in the
wilderness nothing that Dr Friedrich
told him that there was no war or that
the foundation was not affiliated with
the US government could convince him
otherwise and he refused to talk further
before a second interview was conducted
batov was given an old copy of the level
one researcher General debrief as a way
of helping him further understand the
nature of the foundation and his
containment batro was more Cooperative
after that though the realization that
he would most likely be kept in
containment for the rest of his life
caused him great distress and he was
unwilling to speak to Dr Friedrich for
another 3 days Dr Friedrich didn't give
up though and when batro finally opened
up to the doctor he began to tell him
more and more batro told the doctor that
when he was a child Russia was hit by an
American nuclear warhead and that the
Soviet Union immediately retaliated the
resulting nuclear conflict which batro
called the war to end the world caused
massive Devastation and left most of the
planet dangerous iously irradiated that
is why he had the exoskeleton it was to
Shield him from the radiation and allow
him to survive above ground
unfortunately batro knew very little
about how the suit was made or how it
worked saying that it was built by the
engineers and that it grew naturally
over a period of several years but
bellatv hadn't made the decision himself
it was his parents who had volunteered
him as a test subject for the
exoskeleton suit program when he was
still young hoping it would give him a
better chance at survival the process of
bonding the exoskeleton to the human
body was extremely painful but according
to batov its advantages far outweigh the
pain the suit not only helped him
survive in a nuclear Wasteland but made
him a better Soldier the suit allowed
him to lift and carry up to 12200 kg
gave him stereoscopic vision and the
organic radio transmitter allowed him to
communicate with other soldiers across
long distances as well as listen in on
encrypted enemy Transmissions the wounds
on his shoulders and arms where it
looked like appendages had been ripped
out were where his weapons and Supply
packs had previously been mounted batro
had been stationed with his men in the
area he was discovered when they were
attacked by American soldiers the
soldiers had ripped off bellator's
weapons and Supply pack and did the same
to all his men as well they were all
shot with batov being spared for the
moment only because the Americans had
identified him as the commanding officer
suddenly there was a bright flash of
light and the American soldiers vanished
not only that but the landscape changed
where there had been a post nuclear
Wasteland before now there were lush
green trees injured and disoriented
batov began sending distress signals
only to have those signals intercepted
by the SCP Foundation the most
interesting part of bov's story as far
as the foundation was concerned Cain
during his fourth interview when Dr
Friedrich asked him about the the
engineers who had designed the
exoskeleton suit in bov's own words they
weren't truly known to man until the
years of the Great War and the
revolution the French found them in
buried cities where the Western allies
were digging their trenches eventually
they were made to build weapons for the
war by both sides by his description
these Engineers didn't sound human but
they were by no means unknown to the SCP
Foundation belov described the engineers
as humanoid nocturn
covered in fur and possessing technology
and intelligence far beyond that of any
human those familiar with the
foundation's history might already know
the engineers by their Foundation
designation of SCP 1000 or their more
commonly known name Bigfoot a quick
rundown SCP 1000 are a species of
intelligent humanoid primates that lived
alongside Humanity in highly advanced
cities until their own technology was
turned against them not only were their
cities wiped off the face of the Earth
but 70% of their population was
slaughtered and the survivors were
driven mad to the point that their
mental faculties were no higher than
those of a chimpanzee or gorilla the SCP
Foundation is tasked with keeping them
away from Human contact in fear of what
the creatures would be able to do to
humanity if they ever regained their
memories and full mental function and
rumors have been spread about them
possessing deadly anomalous properties
but evidently the destruction of the SCP
1,000 species never occurred in bellat
tr's universe or if it did it wasn't
nearly as complete in that timeline
Humanity regained contact with SCP 1000
after discovering their underground
cities sometime during World War I after
this discovery both Allied and access
powers began recruiting them to build
weapons and their weapons played a role
in both the Russian Revolution and the
second world war it was because of these
technological advantages that the Cold
War escalated into what would become the
war to end all wars both sides were
armed with not only nuclear warheads but
highly Advanced radiation proof
exoskeleton armor that allowed the
conflict to continue even after the
total Destruction of the planet while
the humans fought above ground life
continued as normal for SCP 1000 in
their underground cities as batro noted
they never wore the armor themselves as
they had no need to venture above ground
only soldiers wear armor and this is not
their War batro continued to adjust to
life in containment and sitting for
regular interviews with Dr Friedrich he
was given the rations provided for
humanoid anomalies but in much larger
quantities as the suit required him to
eat around 8,000 calories a day to keep
it functioning bellat trov also began
taking advantage of his ability to
access the foundation's library he would
often read or listen to classical music
particularly by the Russian composer
chaikovsky he seemed especially fond of
reading the time Machine by HG WS no
surprise given he was able to directly
relate to the experience of living
through an apocalypse and being
transported to a strange timeline with
no way to return home but with little
else to occupy his time bellatv began to
display symptoms consistent with
post-traumatic stress disorder reporting
in his now regular interviews with Dr
friederick that he was constantly
reliving memories of the battles he'd
fought and the lives he had taken in
combat the suit was making the problems
wor too it seemed it was as if he could
never forget as one of its features was
an ability to store and replay memories
this feature was intended as a strategic
Aid that would allow commanding officers
to more effectively gather and process
information about their surroundings but
outside of combat this only served to
force batov into reliving his most
painful memories again and again every
night as he tried to sleep he would see
the faces of his men their weapons torn
from their exos skeletons laying in the
dirt after being gunned down by the
enemy like many veterans bellatv was
being hit all at once with the harsh
realities of War now that his brain
wasn't solely focused on keeping him
alive it had time to process all the
horrors he'd experienced he told Dr
friederick I trained alongside these men
for years before they put us back on the
surface since we were all young children
we were brothers and I gave them the
order to surrender and got them killed I
should have died with them while the
story of SCP 2273 ends here the story of
Alexi batov SCP
22731 continues in 2018 vetrov was
allowed passage to vrad Russia as part
of an anomaly reintegration program
while he was unable to secure employment
within the Russian government as he had
hoped he eventually was taken in by a
monastery and continued to write letters
to Dr friederick until fried's eventual
death from lymphoma related
complications there's plenty more on the
monastery the anomaly reintegration
program and what happened to Major
bellatv when he returned to Russia but
that will have to be a story for another
day the helicopter lurched and rumbled
as it made its descent through the virco
yanin mountain range conditions were
harsh with Fierce winds ripping Through
The Valleys at any point a blizzard
threatened to strike just about managing
to touchdown mobile task force Lambda 9
was glad to be out of the vehicle even
if it meant stepping into kneee snow
there were eight operatives in total
early reconnaissance suggested that they
were the only people present within a 5
km radius at least that's certainly what
they hoped L9 operatives 1 through six
all made their way up through the
mountain pass leaving seven and eight
guarding the chopper this was a simple
reconnaissance mission they would need
to search the bunker for any signs of
Life Gathering Intel and get out
hopefully before the snowstorm hit all
eight of them were kitted out with the
foundation's ker grade Cutting Edge
anti- cionic plating the operatives had
all been chosen carefully with L 9-1 the
leader being an experienced Soldier
serving 11 years in the unit he had
capable psionic Powers himself and
approached L 9-2 who showed some of the
same gifts all of a sudden as the group
rounded the final pass and caught sight
of the facility both one and two EXP
experiened severe migraines battered by
the Russian wind they had no choice but
to get to the bunker as fast as possible
it looked relatively unassuming a small
concrete slab sitting amongst the
mountains the six of them gathered
around on either side of the doors as
number three forced his way inside
following standard breaching Maneuvers
the rest of the team followed suit
charging in through the open doorway and
immediately tipping forward into an
abyss they all landed hard side by side
on on the slope some of them rolling
down clattering against each other and
eventually skidding to a stop very
gingerly the groups started to get back
to their feet and catch their breath as
the wind had been knocked out out of all
of them they weren't in a research
facility at all the Soviet concrete
walls they had been expecting the old
computers and the lab equipment were all
missing instead they were standing in a
void infinite and white with no seeming
end in any direction beneath their feet
and curling up above them was an
enormous double helix a rainbow of
colors weaving in and out of one another
it was like they had found themselves
standing on an enormous strand of DNA
floating all around them were glowing
orbs of light none of them could tell
how near or far these orbs were they
could have been close enough to reach
out and touch or they could have been on
the other side of the universe and
slowly one by one they noticed the
doorway that they had come in through it
was perp icular to the double helix and
floating about 3 m above their heads
through it they could see the snowy
Russian Mountains their only chance of
Escape four murmured something about
needing to leave one argued back at him
they had no idea whether that door was
real or an illusion they had no idea if
they would even be able to pass through
it besides it was 3 m above their heads
and floating out over the void it was
risky but for didn't care much about
receiving permission taking a few two
steps back further down the double helix
to get a good run up he braced himself
and sprinted as fast as he could before
jumping and reaching for the open
doorway it was as if gravity was
suddenly much stronger as soon as he
stepped off the double helix four was
wrenched downwards tumbling and spinning
accelerating faster and faster he let
out a petrified scream that sent the
other operatives cowering there was no
bottom at least not as far as they could
see or hear for's body just got smaller
and smaller smaller and his screams
quieter and quieter for several minutes
until the agents couldn't hear him
anymore and yet inside the heads of one
and two the psionic members of the group
that screaming sound only seemed to grow
louder December 25th
1962 a man walked briskly through the
West Berlin train station he' shaved his
head the night before and trimmed his
beard down to a thick mustache dark
sunglasses covered his eyes and a fedora
was tipped forward he hoped that his
limp was convincing as he shuffled his
way through the crowds one advantage of
wearing dark sunglasses in the middle of
winter was that he could constantly scan
the faces of those around him looking
for anybody who looked Russian his train
had been delayed an hour outside of
Berlin the train had ground to a halt
German police officers had walked the
length of the carriages checking
everyone's tickets and passports it felt
like an eternity the man was too old by
this point to attempt to run away
besides running through rural Germany in
the snow didn't sound like the best plan
so he stuck to his cover story and hoped
against hope that the fake passport he
bought would be convincing enough
fortunately for him the officer checked
it he looked to be about 18 years old
the man doubted that the boy would know
a Russian passport if it was signed by
Nikita kushev himself but shuffling
through the station his feeling of
unease grew Russian deserters had been
poisoned all around him for the prior 15
years a number of his own colleagues had
mysteriously gone missing after feeling
disenfranchised by the Soviet agenda he
was such a high-profile Target that
there was no way the KGB wasn't actively
hunting him down at that very moment he
clutched the briefcase tightly and made
his way out of the station his plan had
been to call a taxi but now the prospect
of being alone in an anonymous vehicle
with only one other person terrified him
his best protection would be to stay out
in the open as much as possible he would
walk to the British Embassy or rather
he'd pretend to limp there Lambda 9
operatives number seven and 8 stood by
the helicopter shivering their team had
been missing for hours now and they
could see the blizzard slowly covering
the mountain range like a blanket before
long it would reach them if their
helicopter got buried by anything more
than a couple of inches all hopes of
evacuating back to base would be dashed
as soon as the their team had gone
through the doors into the facility all
radio contact with them had been cut off
the foundation had suspected that the
bunker would be heavily insulated but if
that were the case surely one of them
would have stepped outside to resume
radio contact and report what they had
found so far then all of a sudden seven
went limp he remained standing but his
head and shoulders slumped forward as if
he'd fallen asleep perhaps he had been
standing out here for too long a was
about to Rouse him when suddenly seven
started talking hello eight can you hear
me it's one are you there the
conversation moved quickly somehow one
had been able to reach out to s's mind
and temporarily take control in order to
use him as a mouthpiece to communicate
with the foundation over the radio this
kind of contact would normally have been
well beyond what one would have been
capable of but he explained that as soon
as they had entered the facility both he
and two had felt their powers growing
immeasurably the foundation asked for a
situation report and one updated them
about what had happened to four trying
to escape through the door he jumped and
fell through the abyss but what was more
sickening was that they had seen for
again all of a sudden they had started
to hear his screams physically not
psionically and he had fallen past them
just off to their right almost within
touching distance having decided that it
was too risky to attempt an escape as
four had done the group of them made the
decision to travel further down into the
facility descending along the Helix for
the next 3 hours s is unresponsive he
stands there limp in the snow hunched
forward and not speaking despite eight
and the foundation's best attempts to
wake him command we found something the
Helix branches off a bit there's a
doorway there I can see inside it looks
like a lab of some kind we can walk to
it hopefully it's a way out command sent
authorization for them to proceed and so
they did one reported that it appeared
that they were back in the real world
the abstract shapes and colors the
infinite void was gone they were in a
Soviet research lab there was medical
equipment everywhere syringes and jars
full of well maybe it's best not to know
what was in them as Lambda 9 walked
through the facility checking every
corner before rounding out they felt a
profound sense of unease surely enough
that feeling was warranted rounding the
corner one found some human remains the
man appeared to have been a researcher
at one point his brains were now
stretched out and stuck to the walls
like Silly Putty what the hell happened
here safely on British soil the man who
had defected from the Soviet Union sat
in the interview room chewing his bottom
lip he had spent so much time focusing
on how he would escape with his life
that he hadn't spared much thought for
what he would say once he was on the
other side they had codenamed him Iceman
but he didn't feel particularly cold at
that moment he felt nervous but he did
his best to hide it I was he project
manager in the psychotronics division of
the main intelligence directorate I
oversaw project Redline which was
commissioned by Joseph Stalin following
the second world war and before he knew
what he was doing he told his
interviewer everything over 20 million
Soviets had died during the second world
war their death toll eclipsed that of
any other country Iceman had witnessed
it all so in Stalin had come to him with
the task of creating an ultra powerful
psychic weapon something that could
convert the the entire world population
to adopt Marxism leninism the man had
his reservations activating a device
like that could trigger a war even
deadlier than either of the two already
experienced that Century he was part of
Gru division P the Russian arm of Highly
classified experimental research
conferring with his team they devised a
plan they would argue they needed
absolute secrecy to carry out their work
even away from the watching eyes of the
KGB rather than create a weapon they
would create a tool for peace instead of
promoting the values of Communism they
would create a psychic tool to dampen
Humanity's inclination towards violence
and aggression their method would be
brutal but unnecessary evil in short
their theory was the psychic mind is
often limited by the human body a young
child could have incredible psychic
potential but their physical limitations
would hold them back from exercising it
therefore they needed to separate mind
from body and they had just the trick
for that traumatic disassociation they
would take a young gifted psychic and
tear out their mind in order to transfer
that mind into the body of a
controllable Avatar Iceman explained
that none of them could have expected
how much fate would look favorably on
them just 2 years prior the KGB had
captured and brought in a set of
triplets for them the triplets were
incredibly rare conjoined at both the
head and the Torso with three arms and
six legs it was a miracle they were
still alive so Iceman and his team set
to work immediately they dosed the
triplets up with as many mind-altering
chemicals as they could physically
endure before electrocuting them for
prolonged periods whilst reading antiv
violent manifestos to them it worked the
triplets minds disassociated and the
Soviets were able to capture it Iceman
was not forthcoming about what they did
with the mind or where they transferred
it all he explained was that it worked
they took the weapon to the norlock
gulock 50,000 of the most vicious
criminals known to man Luthers murderers
Psychopaths dropped their makeshift
knives and refused to move an inch even
as we threw the gates of the camp wide
open we did that the final test was on
Nikita Kev and John F Kennedy from
thousands of kilometers away they
activated project Redline and influenced
the two world leaders at the height of
the Cuban Missile Crisis war was averted
but crev was Furious he removed the
entire team killing a number of them and
began to weaponize project Redline if
they could fire it at an advancing Army
they'd never lose a single soldier ever
again to do this it needed to be
stronger they were to implant the
Consciousness into another subject
torture them further and disassociate
again amplifying the psychic abilities
mobile task force Lambda 9 were stuck in
the facility the blizzard had been so
strong that seven and eight had to
return to base the previous night and
come back having spent a night lost in
wandering through the Helix descending
deeper and deeper the team had noticed
that the world around them was getting
darker periodically they could hear
Force screaming and falling past them
once again before dropping out of sight
again beneath them they had tried to
catch him to pull him back but he was
always just Out Of Reach desperate to be
saved seven and8 returned and their
psychic puppet radio contact was resumed
with command the team found another door
searching through it they were horrified
to find their own corpses floating in
the air air in front of them dressed up
in lab coats just like the scientists
from the levels above them their brains
were stretching out and lying together
in some kind of web yet further down the
Helix they found another door one and
three decided to go inside leaving the
rest of the team standing on the Helix
ready to catch four if he fell past
again this time two was in contact with
command through his psychic link to the
men by the chopper he soon reported
hearing for's screams getting closer and
closer the group stood around ready to
catch him there he is I can see him he's
definitely Falling Towards us yeah I see
it too command there's something up with
for it looks like he's spread eagled his
arms are stretched out he's he's
screaming it's not getting louder it's
getting flatter there would be no
further contact with two five and six by
the time one and three returned from
scouting out the room they were alone
one couldn't even sense the presence of
any of their squadmates anymore they had
no option but to continue to descend the
Helix into the darkness
the smell of burning flesh filled their
noses The Echoes of death were all
around them voices cried out in pain and
fear and then new voices speaking in
Russian cut over the top stop it give in
don't resist resisting is bad you will
be punished if you resist begin
electrical discharge 500 volts 3 amps
increase voltage every minute the
operatives had no choice but to listen
to the memory of the triplets being
being tortured not just the sounds but
the emotions that flood them those
weren't someone else's memories anymore
they were becoming their own and just as
they saw into the mind of the triplets
the triplets saw them in return
commandants trying to open me up like it
did everyone else but I can see into it
it's learning from us it knows all about
me the squad the foundation they're
almost on me it's it's the conjunction
the scientists the monsters that made
this thing the ones it knew before died
was that they wanted it to conjunct it
wants to make us part of it don't come
back here it wants to make the whole
world part of it and at that moment the
entirety of mobile task force Lambda 9
dropped dead in that same moment a
multicolored sphere of energy 5 km wide
appeared over the facility dwarfing the
mountains around it designated SCP 2664
daa for years the foundation dropped
psionically dampening materials and
psionically stumped d-class Personnel
into the sphere in hopes of slowing its
growth no other containment measures
could be acted upon that was until 1300
hours on the 25th of December 2000
Christmas Day SCP 2664 daa suddenly
fluctuated releasing an enormous amount
of psionic energy that resulted in the
brain death of all humans within a km
radius the following day at 1700 hours a
global cult Coalition satellite launched
a spherical payload right into the heart
of SCP 2664 daa for 13 minutes
tremendous amounts of radiation were
detected emanating from inside the
sphere before just as suddenly as it had
appeared SCP 2664 d a disappeared
entirely leaving just the payload in its
place before the foundation was able to
recover the payload it launched into the
atmosphere and was lost subsequent
reconnaissance operations to the site
have confirmed no abnormal radioactive
or psionic readings to all intents and
purposes SCP 2664 appears to be gone as
such the file has been marked as
neutralized long may it stay that way
the diver screams A Silent Scream as the
giant Squid's beak digs into his skin
it's many grasping tentacles grabbing
him and holding him in place nearby his
fellow divers are driven half mad with
Terror as they see mysterious figures
floating towards them through the Merc
and strange Russian voices speaking in
their heads nobody can help them they're
down too deep too consumed by the
darkness and the pressure of the sea
they're now at the mercy of whatever is
inside the submarine beginning in the
1940s with the dawn of nuclear weapons
the American government conducting the
world's first atomic weapons test and
the Soviet Union responding in kind with
nuclear testing of their own the two
Powers entered an arms race fueled by
rivalry and a thirst to prove their
strength on the world stage What
followed were Decades of Staggering
technological advancements as each
Nation tried to outdo and intimidate the
other the Soviet Union crossed into the
cold reaches of outer space deploying
the satellite Sputnik the United States
responded with the founding of NASA
tensions reached a fever pitch during
the Cuban Missile Crisis of 1962 as
United States citizens feared they were
teetering on on the brink of nuclear war
in July of 1968 the Soviet Union the
United Kingdom and the United States
came together to sign the treaty on the
nonproliferation of nuclear weapons
agreeing to abandon their pursuit of
increasing nuclear power and turn their
focus to disarmament but several months
before the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a submarine known as SCP
741 SCP 741 is the underwater wreckage
of a Soviet submarine that sank in March
of 1968 and came into the custody of the
SCP Foundation in 1999 the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the US
government launched project redacted
which is attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 1970s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible uclid or
ker class anomaly in the rck at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hole was broken
into bits during project redactor
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they seem to have left something behind
whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices and incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
Additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a man Expedition into
the waters around the wreckage described
in incident report
1741a divers a26 through a30 embarked
from the ice breaker yamal into the
waters below with the intention of
studying the potential anomalous
activity surrounding the wreckage as the
group of divers approached the submarine
they could feel the shift in the water
around them the oppressive feeling of
abnormally increasing pressure bearing
down and threatening to crush them if
their specialized diving equipment were
to fail they knew that that would be yet
and the command would have to come and
fish their corpses out of the water or
even worse they would vanish entirely
meeting the same mysterious fate as the
crew of that doomed submarine but they
couldn't fix it on that they had a job
to do at first glance the wreckage
appeared undisturbed unchanged since the
previous inspection still they needed to
take a closer look to be sure as the
team got closer to the vessel a30 was
startled by the sight of movement from
within the wreckage spotting motion
through one of the holes in the
structure as something passed by he
pointed it out to his colleagues but
they dismissed it as likely a giant
isopod or spider crab which were
crawling all over the surrounding area
a30 laughed off his jumpiness agreed
that they were probably right and
continued the exploration as planned
control authorized the divers to proceed
to the next step and a29 activated sonar
and lights moving toward the starboard
side breach there a faint glowing caught
his eye the glow resembled that of
radioactive material but when the team
checked the radiation levels in the area
they remained stable whatever the source
of the glow was it wasn't radioactive at
this point his Neutron counter began to
register something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
vili yini can you hear me the voice was
muffled and though it could be heard
over their communication channels it
emanated from somewhere in the wreckage
deep deep underwater as a29 watched a
glowing shape emerge from the darkness
it was only an outline the suggestion of
a silhouette but the shape was
undeniably familiar it looked like a
person the other divers quickly noted
the apparation 2 and began to panic some
checked their nitrogen levels believing
it to be some sort of nitrogen Narcosis
While others pointed out that they
couldn't all be suffering from nitrogen
Narcosis at the same time the unknown
voice continued speaking saying help me
it is getting hard to breathe the divers
debated what to do next questioning
whether what they were seeing was even
real when all at once the humanoid
figure vanished from sight the divers
attempted to shake off the startling
encounter and they resumed their duties
the investigation proceeding as normal
after a few moments of uneventful work
another Interruption presented itself in
the form of a 5 meter long squid
swimming around the wreckage its
presence startled the divers at first
particularly those was closest to the
animal but the others encouraged them to
ignore it citing the fact that there are
no records of these squid attacking
humans so they did continuing their work
as the squids circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible in order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but the sight of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that it resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of SCP 714 diver a26 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attacking squid his camera was
destroyed in the process as squid are
not known to attack humans unprovoked
this Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of SCP 741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the wreck with a
radius of approximately 250 M starting
around the center of the submarine the
pressure in this area is much greater
than it should be given the depth of the
waters there this unusually high
pressure makes sonar analysis extremely
difficult as well as threatening the
safety of any divers in the vicinity of
the rack the few records that the
foundation has managed to obtain from
the Russian and US governments indicate
that the submarine was being used to
transport some sort of secret cargo
though the specifics of this cargo are
still unknown there is reason to believe
that it differed from any type of
nuclear or chemical Weaponry on a date
redacted from official files the scps
basist was patrolling the area around
SCP 741 when its sonar detected some
unknown entity approaching SCP 741 from
the south at a pace of 46 knots the crew
compared the acoustic signature of the
contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
bisti attempted to reach the contact via
sonab buoi drops and active sonar pings
but it did not respond when the contact
crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone it became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an undersea missile launch and
basti responded with the utmost urgency
the ship broke away from its original
area and fired a type 53 torpedo at the
underwater threat 15 seconds after the
basti launched its torpedo missiles of
an unidentified configuration were seen
breaking the water flying at a height of
1.8 m and a velocity of .92 Mach the
missiles did not emit any detectable
radar nor did they respond to any launch
chaff or flares from the basti both of
the missiles were engaged by bti's 3K N5
Kinsel surfac to- aair missiles and
cachan point defense systems and were
destroyed at 1800 M and 210 M from
Impact respectively
after the missiles were neutralized the
Hostile vessel could be heard engaging
in evasive maneuvers at this point there
were four closely spaced explosions and
the sound of a submarine disintegrating
the identity of the attacker as well as
its intention toward SCP 741 have not
yet been determined the incident
resulted in the foundation research team
suggesting an expansion of the acoustic
sensor net as well as additional Patrol
and defense assets placed in the area
additionally they advised an acquisition
of underc retaliatory capability the
incident was classified incident 1741 DC
the sonar recordings from the scps bisti
during incident 1741 DC were taken for
further analysis by the research team
the in-depth review revealed anomalous
acoustic signatures that did not match
up with any known forms of propulsion
including Magneto hydrodynamic Drive
currently the nature of the unidentified
attacker remains a mystery and it has
not been attributed to any particular
government government or organization
following the incident involving the
scps bisti an American intelligence
agent reached out to the foundation
offering further insight into the
secretive government programs looking
into SCP 741 he agreed to sit for an
interview with a foundation researcher
assigned to the project on the condition
that his identity remained protected the
SCP researcher's name is absent from the
official file as well the two men sat in
a foundation interview room and the
interviewer asked his forant why he
chose to come forward given the US
government had simply chosen to sit on
this information for 30 years you've
seen those reports project redacted now
we know that part too how the directors
didn't make the connection is beyond me
that and the stuff that redacted pulled
up yeah the other part you don't hear
about is what some of the research team
died of and the crew Men We buried Just
Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward by the
director and didn't is something I can't
fully explain this particular statement
puzzled the foundation researcher
raising questions he hadn't anticipated
only uniforms did this mean that the sub
had been unmanned the informant replied
no no not unmanned there were no bodies
but personal effects were everywhere
along with uniforms there was some blood
human before you ask on one of the
Torpedoes in a bit of skin where
somebody probably crushed his hand
loading the thing just no bodies left
when I first looked into all this I had
no clue what the hell had gone on down
there but I started putting things
together the foundation agent began to
speculate based on the mounting evidence
could it have been a Soviet weapons
program a deadly biological agent of
some kind no no it wasn't that I thought
maybe it could have been so I dialed up
some of my contacts at v preparent as
spies wind up owing each other favors
after a while and they denied it vly not
your usual cover up baloney either they
clearly stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they want to
know part of it sound like he was going
to puke when I mentioned redacted doctor
do you have any idea what it takes to
make a bow weapons researchers sick now
that wasn't what really bugged me though
what really kept me awake at night was
the KGB file that fell into our hands
they mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal named
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the US of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too loan and you
half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that SCP 741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships scps bisti and Kar has
been selected for this purpose if any
unauthorized activity occurs in the area
surrounding SCP 741 nuclear and
conventional missiles may be deployed
any movement of SCP 7 41 is grounds for
an immediate Nuclear Strike whatever
Secrets as CP 741 holds whatever it was
transporting that was even more of an
uncontrollable threat than nuclear
warfare they're better left alone down
there at the bottom of the sea your new
SCP Foundation researcher on tour of
site 17 familiarizing yourself with the
location and its many anomalous
inhabitants it's the second largest
Foundation containment site out there
and it's also the kind of job that most
Junior research dream of lowrisk
humanoid containment baby most of the
inhabitants in your sector are cordial
willing to comply with orders from staff
and seem for all intents and purposes
pretty much human you pass from door to
door looking through the viewing hatch
of each one you can't believe what
you're seeing it's a wonderful who's who
of anomalous humanoids you see the wise
bearded face of SCP 343 known to some as
God you see the blue eyes and Shining
blonde hair of Iris as scp-105 looking
wistfully into a Polaroid picture you
see the tanned melancholic face of Cain
SCP 073 as he stares off into the middle
distance face after face after face
passes you can see yourself getting more
familiar with each one yes your time
here will be wait was that Hitler you
stop and walk back to the door you just
passed where you can't help but stop and
stare in disbelief yes it's him it's got
to be him you recognize the unpleasant
sneer the Hideous combover the silly
little toothbrush mustache the SCP
Foundation seems to have Adolf Hitler
the former leader of the Third Reich in
World War II in active containment and
his designation is SCP 2430 you've seen
Killer toasters and masks that can take
over people's minds but you've never
seen anything as surreal as this you
immediately run to your Superior and ask
how and why Hitler is in one of the
sight 17 humanoid containment cells
Buckle in because we can guarantee it's
one of the most insane stories you've
ever heard it's late April 1945 and the
Soviets are rampaging through Nazi
Germany destroying everything in their
path the German forces have been nearly
obliterated and Hitler and the rest of
his Reich chancellory have retreated to
a secure bunker beneath Berlin there on
April 30th 10 days after his 56th
birthday Hitler died this was truly
unfortunate for the Soviets as they wish
to have had the chance to kill him
themselves 2 Days Later Soviet forces
stormed the furer bunker it was little
more than a formality at that point as
the news of Hitler's death had already
gone public by the time they arrived all
that was left of Hitler was a pile of
mostly burned remains A fitting end for
someone who had caused the same cruel
fate for so many others they collected
what was left of Hitler's body and
brought it back to the Fatherland a kind
of trophy for their Nation but Hitler
dying before Joseph Stalin could get his
hands on him was not what Stalin wanted
Hitler had not only caused the deaths of
millions of Russians he had personally
betrayed Stalin's trust and when you
betray Stalin bad things happen to you
very very bad things 2 years earlier in
1943 Soviet forces had raided a camp in
jska belonging to the obscura corpse
think of them as the Nazis own version
of the SCP Foundation who were hellbent
on Gathering anomalous people and
artifacts to increase the power of the
Third Reich they were a far more
militant offshoot of the TU Society a
group that described itself as a study
group for Germanic Antiquity while this
may seem innocent that tuo Society was
actually a racist cult closely aligned
with the goals and ideas of the German
Nazi party many have also speculated
that they were heavily involved in the
occult and it's this mysticism obsessed
offshoot that went on to form the
obscura corpse and in their janosa base
they had obtained a 100 pieces of
Enchanted occult flesh with human
skeletons embedded in each of them this
flesh was believed to originate from the
mythological simir the Beast hunted and
eaten again and again by the pantheon of
Norse gods having the qualities of both
a wild boar and a goat the flesh can
bond to skeletons and give them a
quality somewhat like immortality any
flesh cut from them will regrow time and
time again if given a rest period now
that he had both the Flesh of serir and
Hitler's burnt remains Stalin had an
idea a perfect way to not only bring
satisfaction to the Russian people and
the world but to finally exact the true
Revenge that Hitler had denied to him he
called it project judica namely after
the very bottom level of Hell reserve
for betrayers like Judas a perfect
tribute for an old Ally turned enemy he
couldn't kill Hitler before but if
Stalin was going to get the chance
Hitler needed to live again for years
Stalin's top scientists tried to use
Arcane methods to resurrect Hitler by
combining his remains with the Flesh of
surir at times they even came close to
creating a new Hitler but there was one
huge issue the creature they created
could not feel pain and for Stalin's
plans of violent and painful retribution
the lack of suffering simply would not
do they destroyed what they had created
and went back to the drawing board
Stalin would stop at nothing to get what
he wanted even if it meant breaking
every law of nature in the process in
order to make his Twisted dream a
reality Stalin formed an Unholy alliance
with a group known as the uralic flesh
Crafters a neocar cult that was a branch
of the nightmarish religion of sarcasm
this group essentially worshiped avatars
of Flesh corruption and disease and are
behind some of the most terrifying and
disgusting anomalies out there including
the flesh that hates and the bone
Orchard true sarcus ists who show the
proper Devotion to their vile deities
and know the right rituals to contact
them are often granted anomalous powers
that spread the saric influence further
across the known Dimensions these Powers
will usually involved having a
supernatural ability to manipulate the
Flesh of themselves and others allowing
them to enhance their bodies cheat death
and warp their enemies Beyond repair
they can sometimes even create life if
if they're a powerful enough acolyte of
sarcasm and it was because of these
powers that Stalin wanted the Eric flesh
Crafters under his command in exchange
for their participation he would give
them a vast quantity of the Flesh of
surir which they could use for their own
Sinister saric purposes a deal was
struck and the true work of resurrecting
Hitler began Stalin was very specific in
his requirements he gave the Eric flesh
Crafters extra bones to compensate for
what had gone missing from Hitler's
burnt remains he also gave them samples
of the Flesh of surir to achieve the
desired effects of a near Immortal
tolerance for damage however Stalin
demanded that he heighten this new
Hitler's capacity to experience pain so
that every suffering inflicted on him
would be three times worse than anyone
else and true to their word the flesh
Crafters got to work and began creating
just such a creature by now it was the
early 1950s and Stalin was putting the
pieces in place for his Grand venge once
the new Hitler was finished he would
hold a new trial for him in the Russian
courts where he would preside over the
sentencing personally once the new
Hitler was done the Eric flesh Crafters
were rewarded for their participation in
project judica with 4,000 kg of the
Flesh of surir Stalin now had his very
own personal Hitler chew toy that he
could maim and torture as much as he
pleased knowing that he would always
heal and soon be ready for more in their
infinite generosity the flesh Crafters
even taught Stalin a new method of
Torment for his old enemy a process
known as the right of Neos it's a
torture that's been described by many as
being like the Chinese lingi also known
as the lingering death or slow slicing
but it is probably best known as the
death by a Thousand Cuts the Soviets and
the saric parted ways for the next few
years Stalin took a great deal of
pleasure in visiting Hitler's cage now
and then to torture him until Stalin
himself self eventually passed away from
natural causes the grup division which
is essentially the Soviet answer to the
SCP Foundation decided it would be best
to do away with the immortal Hitler
clone after Stalin's death he no longer
served any purpose and no matter how
hard they tried they couldn't
permanently kill him either in the end
they settled on a kind of compromise he
would be buried alive and forgotten
forced to live a torturous eternity that
he could never Escape until of course he
was dug up in been rescued by none other
than the members of obscura a modern
splinter group of the original obscura
corpse like many high-profile nais who'd
escaped the war the new Hitler was
Spirited Away to a safe house run by
sympathizers in Argentina the ones
taking care of him received the
following correspondents from the
obscura agents who'd first dug the new
Hitler back up they have managed to
rescue Zira and bring him to safety but
he is effectively dead on the inside I
blame the Reds for their inhumane
treatment of the f who may have been
Beed by the red vavaa I wish we could
mercy kill him but we've tried
everything he just won't perish don't
abandon him he's too distinct in plain
sight they didn't have the new Hitler
for long though in 1960 efforts to hunt
down the remaining Nazi fugitives
increased in intensity the new Hitler
was soon captured by mad agents
searching for Nazis in Buenos Ares and
then remanded to the containment of the
SCP Foundation when they realized that
he had a number of anomalous properties
such as his incredible regenerative
abilities as well as the fact that his
DNA seems to be based on that of a wild
boar and a goat rather than a human
however x-rays conducted by the
foundation have discovered traces of
cyanide still in his system as well as
traces of lead in his skull where the
bone has regrown over the bullet in
other words it was unquestionably the
real Hitler and he was now in Foundation
custody forever more it's such a wild
story even by Foundation standards that
you can barely SU the words to respond
once your supervisor is finished he just
stands there with a slight smile basking
in your amazement before you can even
ask again he confirms the facts one more
time yes it is the real Hitler the only
functional difference is that he can't
die and he has a heightened sense of
pain compared to most people you think
on what you've been told for just a
moment and then you have only one
question are we allowed to punch him
your supervisor smiles and says of
course we all do cast your mind back to
the high of the Cold War the ever
accelerating nuclear arms race brought
us closer than ever before to making the
nightmare of nuclear Armageddon a
terrifying reality the two main parties
in this conflict are the United States
and Soviet Union each amassing huge
amounts of nuclear warheads and jumping
on any available Advantage they can over
their enemies what you may not know is
that in order to detect an impending
attack from the United States the
Soviets developed what would become
known to the West as the dead hand but
this experimental piece of technology
also had another name SCP
1984 it is no secret that the Soviet
Union feared the threat of US nuclear
strikes an invasion just as much as the
US feared an attack from them so SCP
1984 was created to act as a deterrence
mechanism specifically against secure
second strikes secure second strikes
were both a deterrent and overwhelming
concern during the Cold War referring to
a country's ability after suffering an
initial nuclear attack to still
retaliate firing on their enemy and
causing Untold damage with their own
arsenal of nuclear weapons the Soviet
Union knew that any action they made
that could be perceived as an attack on
United States soil would be threatened
with nuclear retaliation and that if
they fired First America would return
fire and potentially annihilate them
with the second strike SCP 1984 was to
be an automated system that would
activate in response to the destruction
of the soviet's main command and control
structure given that the Dead Hand was
created during the80s you might be
forgiven for expecting a nuclear
detection system built at this point in
history to consist of various sensors
connected to a computer network but you
have also probably already realized that
if this was the case then the foundation
wouldn't be so interested in it in
actuality SCP 1984 is a fully autonomous
entity rather than a network of sensors
ERS for detecting incoming nuclear
strikes or a computer capable of
initiating a second strike perhaps what
makes the foundation more interested in
the Dead Hand is that it is both
self-aware and links simultaneously to
every single one of Russia's nuclear
launch sites not only this but SCP 1984
also has direct access to every single
one of the atomic weapons stockpiled by
the Soviet Union during the Cold War and
is capable of launching Intercontinental
ballistic missiles at a moment's notice
in short SCP 1984 could very easily and
horrifyingly quickly trigger an allout
nuclear war resulting in the extinction
of all life on Earth no wonder the
foundation considers the dead hands such
a massive threat SCP 1984 itself
actually consists of the preserved
remains of a Russian soldier by the name
of Sergeant morat chernikov who was
killed during the Soviet Afghan war in
198 2 most of the official documentation
of chernov's existence has been expunged
by the Russian Federation and he is only
referred to in fragmented documents
recovered by the foundation that
referred to a project December these
remains serve as the location of a semi-
sentient Consciousness that has been
classified as SCP
19841 when it remains dormant and is not
interfered with SCP
19841 has the ability to receive and
process any signal broadcast to it and
is is able to decipher information
combined in any signal it picks up
however when global Military tensions
start to climb especially when those
tensions affect the Russian Federation
or what were once the satellite states
of the former Soviet Union The Entity
begins to manifest itself in the
physical world and usually in various
strange and different ways SCP
19841 has been known to appear in the
real world in forms such as a humanoid
outline or or a bright red Spectre
taking the shape of a child with its
legs cut off regardless of which shape
it appears in it is when the Dead Hand
manifests in a more physical form that
the wider scope of its abilities become
clear as mentioned previously it can
influence and even launch nuclear
weapons overriding their command systems
and bypassing launch sequences after
appearing fully sccp1
19841 will travel at speeds of up to 140
km an hour directly to the nearest
military installation capable of
launching intercontinental ballistic
missiles once it reaches its destination
scp1
19841 will immediately attempt to
override the necessary systems to
initiate a launch after firing missiles
at their predetermined targets scp1
19841 will hastily travel to another
facility housing nuclear ordinance
repeating the process until it has
successfully launched all of Russia's
Atomic weapons when engaged the physical
manifestation of SCP 1984 is highly
aggressive and will lethally defend
itself against anyone that it observes
trying to interfere with it or stop it
from causing a nuclear launch the entity
has displayed the ability to disrupt the
nervous system causing excruciating pain
and debilitating damage to human beings
its only known weakness if any is a
susceptibility to microwave radiation
although exposure to this does not seem
to cause any lasting damage to SCP 1984
instead only temporarily disorienting
its physical form as for the origins of
SCP 1984 the Soviet Union's official
liaison with the SCP Foundation offered
some clarity on this ironically during
early 1984 the liaison a doctor named
Sergey described information regarding
the Dead Hand as being of grave
importance to the continued survival of
the human race seeing as he was
referring to an enemy that could
single-handedly launch the Soviet
Union's entire nuclear Arsenal he
certainly had a point a top secet
Conference was held in sevo between the
foundations 05 Council and officials
from both the USSR and the United States
using the 1984 Winter Olympics as cover
avoiding too many questions about
several Nations high ranking State
officials being in the same place at
once the 05 Council was then given full
indepth information about the Dead Hand
something they had previously assumed
was a more conventional form of nuclear
deterrence SCP 1984 was far more and
worse far out of the control of the
Russian government it was revealed that
the entity had been designated outside
the original specifications given to
those who developed it initially the
Soviets had intended for the Dead Hand
to be solely used as a secure second
strike response if the leaders of the
Soviet Union were killed SCP 1984 would
react in kind to Russia's enemies
launching back all of the ussr's nuclear
missiles in retaliation this is more
likely where the Dead Hand nickname
comes from hearkening to the idea of a
dead man's switch picture that you had
been mortally wounded by your worst
enemy shot in the stomach and laying on
the ground rapidly bleeding out you know
that there is no chance you will survive
but you cannot afford to let your enemy
get away what they don't know is that
you rigged the entire building around
you both with explosives with your dying
breath you activate the Detonator ass
during your own and your enemies Mutual
destruction Kaboom then curtains for
both of you the pressing issue and the
reason this secret Summit between the
USSR USA and SCP Foundation was held was
that SCP 1984 was no longer interested
in just waiting for Russia to be
attacked and only reacting after the
fact instead the entity's physical form
was trying to preemptively strike at the
enemies of the motherland attempting to
activate nuclear launches and send
Atomic weapons to destroy the United
States France West Germany and the
People's Republic of China in other
words the Dead Hand was eager to get a
head start at causing total nuclear
Annihilation not to mention potentially
killing millions and reducing Target
countries to little more than IR
radiated craters a wash with deadly
nuclear fallout both the Soviet Union
and the United States begged the SCP
Foundation to intervene and contain SCP
1984 and under the direction of the 05
Council they stepped in to take direct
control of the situation establishing
new containment procedures in the hopes
of keeping SCP 1984 from hitting as many
launch buttons as it could find the
embalmed remains that seemed to create
the manifestations of the deadhand
entity were held securely in an armed
containment complex near verco yank part
of the Saka Republic within the Russian
Federation SCP 1984 was placed within a
standard humanoid containment cell which
was itself held within a faraday cage a
type of enclosure constructed with or
covered in conductive material designed
to block electromagnetic fields this was
done to block any external broadcast
signals from reaching SCP 1984 and thus
causing it to manifest its other form if
it learned of an impending attack on
Russia even a fictional one perhaps as a
part of a television broadcast as part
of the dead hands Containment all
signals broadcast near its cage are to
be monitored and only broadcasts
featuring doctor information would reach
the entity thankfully to the work of the
SCP foundation's information control
team SCP 1984 is drip fed a stream of
carefully fabricated information using
on-site equipment and Facilities a team
of military historians economists actors
and Soviet media Specialists the
information control team have created an
ongoing narrative wherein the Cold War
never ended through falsified radio and
television broadcasts made to look like
a appropriated news organizations they
managed to keep SCP 1984 convinced that
the nuclear stalemate between the Soviet
Union and United States is still ongoing
unfortunately sometimes information from
The Real World is able to bleed through
an incident involving SCP 1984 occurred
on August 8th 1984 and almost brought
forth a full-scale nuclear war while
preparing for a campaign speech the 40th
President of the United States Ronald
Reagan uttered the following joke I'm
pleased to tell you today that I've
signed legislation that will Outlaw
Russia forever we begin bombing in 5
minutes naturally thousands of media
Outlets reported on this but signals of
those broadcasts including recordings of
the president remark made their way to
SCP 1984 Foundation researchers were
both unsure of how these Transmissions
breached the faray cage surrounding the
Dead Hand and were unable to prevent
what happened next hearing what it could
only assume was a genuine declaration of
war the manifestation of the SCP
19841 entity happened immediately after
Reagan's words reached its containment
cell this time the entity appeared as a
semi-transparent woman withered and blue
wearing traditional pashton dress armed
Personnel guarding SCP 1984's cage
engaged The Entity causing it to
retaliate lashing out and attacking any
that stood in its way one captain and
two privates that suffered the brunt of
SCP 1984's offensive capabilities began
bleeding heavily from their ears seizing
violently most gruesomely of all a
liquid leaked from their eyes and nose
believed to have been cerebros spinal
fluid while armed Personnel attempted to
use microwave emitting Weaponry to slow
The Entity down the information control
team was frantically trying to record a
new falsified broadcast in the hopes
that SCP 1984 would cease its
hostilities and the entity would
dissipate before was able to travel at
high speed to any nearby Soviet nuclear
facilities and begin bombarding the
United States their first attempt to
record a new broadcast that would result
in a cessation of SCP 1984 Slaughter of
its guards was interrupted when a nearby
wall collapsed desperate to recontain
the creature the information control
team tried to film the broadcast a
second time and succeeded although one
of the actors portraying a newsreader
suffered a stroke and had to be edited
out to convince the Dead Hand of its
supposed authenticity What followed was
a short news clip clarifying that
Russia's poit Bureau was in on President
Reagan's joke including old footage of
the ussr's general secretary Constantine
chernenko confirming that the Soviet
Union's nuclear forces were not on high
alert miraculously after 15 more minutes
of sustained fighting with guards SCP
1984's physical manifestation began to
disappear gradually dematerializing
while it seemed to attack with far less
intensity
eventually containment was reestablished
at the cost of the deaths of 17 members
of foundation staff both guards and
researchers a further Aid however
suffered traumatic brain injuries that
left them all permanently disabled the
one upside is that this incident Remains
the only time SCP 1984 has ever breached
its containments and caused harm to
others and considering that it could
very well have launched Russia's nuclear
Arsenal the casualties could easily have
been much higher so remember folks don't
joke about nuclear weapons especially if
you're the president you never know what
anomalies lurking in the bodies of dead
Russian soldiers might be listening and
if they are you'd better hope they have
a sense of humor some say that SCP 2102
was a mistake an Abomination created by
an accident of Medical Science maybe
those people are right maybe there's
much more to it than that either way
they don't know the full story how could
they they weren't there they weren't
there all the way back in
1972 but Dr paval zukal was the earliest
moments the events that directly
preceded SCP 2102 creation began on
March 2nd the wind was carrying an
unforgiving freezing bite with it as
zukal made his way to the Institute of
experimental medicine zav in
Czechoslovakia with the cold war between
the USSR and the United States underway
there was already an erir of secrecy on
both sides Espionage and intelligence
gathering operations were rampant
bringing with them paranoia and distrust
there was no way of knowing if someone
was a double agent leaking information
to the west but while the governments of
Russia America and their various
respective allies and enemies scrambled
for control and had massed obscene
quantities of nuclear arms in secret
there were even more cogs turning hidden
in the deepest darkest Shadows the SCP
found foundation's long-standing rivalry
with various other groups of Interest
was well known among any with a high
enough security clearance most of these
groups were radicals or outliers despite
possessing knowledge of anomalies or
even being directly linked to them a lot
of gois were independent of any world
government but for decades the
foundation had been aware of a directly
competing establishment effectively a
parallel of their own organization on
the other side of the globe they were
known as Gru division p a USSR
equivalent of the SCP Foundation
themselves it is unclear based on what
was recovered from Dr zal's Personal
Diary if he had been directly scouted by
Gru division P for their project in
Czechoslovakia given the air of secrecy
engulfing the USSR at the time it is
possible that pavl himself had no
inclination that division P was even
involved in the project due to take
place at The Institute of experimental
medicine he might have suspected but
with no way of knowing for sure
similarly there was no way zukal could
have known where the project would lead
what he would have a hand in creating
the initial few weeks after his arrival
at The Institute were Rocky to say the
least zukal along with a team of
scientists and technicians working on
orders direct from Moscow had to contend
with unreliable equipment and difficulty
getting electricity to power the project
eventually after clearing those initial
hurdles testing could begin but what was
the goal of this mysterious project
while through zakol Gru division p and
the Kremlin were chasing something the
scientific world has been trying to
accomplish for decades something that
could change the very landscape of not
only the Cold War but the entirety of
modern medicine the secrets of cellular
regeneration unlocking that would in
theory enable them to create the world's
very first unkillable super soldier and
hey it definitely wouldn't be the
craziest Secret operation carried out by
a world superpower during the Cold War
the CIA spent Millions turning a cat
into a listening device and training it
to infiltrate enemy headquarters this
so-called acoustic Kitty was struck and
killed by a random van during its first
mission compared to that a cell
regenerating super soldier was
positively sensible with a worldwide
nuclear arms race already underway
perhaps the Project's ultimate goal was
to produce an entire Army of these
self-regenerating troops with something
like that in their hands the USSR would
have the manpower to reinforce their
nuclear Arsenal and potentially even
soldiers capable of surviving and
healing from the effects of an atomic
blast on the 5th of May
1972 the first of the projects human
test subjects began to show promising
results they underwent physical trauma
at the hands of zukal and the other
scientists only for their bodies to
react much faster than the ordinary
healing process would allow rapid
clotting took place in the affected
areas preventing the subjects from
bleeding out however this quickly went
Ary the clots turned into severe lesions
realizing this had occurred thanks to
maau one of the other project scientists
administering too much neodium zukal
chastised his colleague vowing him to
drag him to Moscow personally if another
mistake like that ever took place again
unfortunately by the last few days of
June Dr zukal and his team were no
closer to success every subject that
underwent test succumbed to the same
necrosis reducing the amount of neodium
had only made the reaction worse
something paval couldn't allow mall to
know without the risk of it being held
over his head for the remainder of the
project in every instance the doctors
were able to trigger rapid cell division
50 times faster than that which occurs
in the ordinary healing process of human
beings but the biggest drawback was that
this division would quickly become
uncontrollable it was creating enough
new matter on a cellular level that it
would choke each test subject in its own
excess waste as you might expect Dr
zukal noted this in his diary that this
process wasn't a pretty sight come mid-
August
1972 the project scientists decided they
needed a test subject with more
resilience than the average person and a
suitable candidate was provided he was a
counterrevolutionary who had been
sentenced to 15 years in a uranium mine
as a punishment detail despite such an
extended period of time under the harsh
conditions of the mind and the close
proximity to a radioactive element such
as uranium the man managed to survive
unscathed upon closer examination this
new guinea pig referred to as x16 had a
rate of healing twice as fast as that of
an average man perhaps it was a random
genetic abnormality that made x16 this
way or maybe it was a result of his
extensive time in the uranium mines
either way it made him the perfect new
subject for zuk's experiment
initially subject x6's preliminary
testing results looked promising the
wound healing process was actually
taking place now instead of resulting in
necrosis or aborting it as it had with
the earlier experiments in fact doctors
ukall seemed to think x16 was healing
almost too quickly but nevertheless
testing continued although not without a
different type of problem the
questionable morality of what they were
doing began to set in for paval causing
him nights of endless tossing and
turning unable to sleep as he reflected
on what he'd done x16 had managed to
survive for much longer than the earlier
test subjects but it was clear that the
torture this man had to endure was
exacting a heavy toll every day the
doctors would lacerate him time and time
again recording the results and every
day he survived only for the cycle to
begin again the next day for his own
part zukal was conflicted on the one
hand the results of the testing were
proving successful lasting far longer
and working far more effectively than
they had in the past and yet on the
other it came at the cost of one man's
continued suffering to make matters
worse a Val had no way of voicing his
concerns to any of his team any
questioning of his orders or the
Project's methods would have been viewed
by Gru division p and the KGB as
sedition and treason earning the good
doctor a one-way ticket to a goog or if
he was lucky a clean shot to the back of
the head from an agent's pistol often
morality is sacrificed for the greater
good in the pursuit of the advancement
of science or a nation's goals but now
that the project was showing results
with x16 now that it was real what they
were doing still weighed heavily on Dr
zuk's conscience then on October 15th
1972 the final piece of the puzzle
seemed to become clear by introducing
the correct amount of stabilizing agent
into the serum they had concocted zukal
and his team had perfected the
composition upon administering this
newly completed version of the solution
the doctor noted in his diary that
subject x16 was responding well at least
medically the subject was responding
well it was clear that the continuous
experimentation he had been subjected to
was causing uncooperative behavior in
x16 but so close to the cusp of
achieving the project goals Dr zukal was
quick to cast aside his previous doubts
about the ethics of their methods they
were so close to Victory so close to the
project being over that it no longer
mattered how Cooperative x16 was being
but 2 weeks and 4 days later just as the
project was nearing its end goal
disaster struck mu Dr Elena orov was one
of the scientists on zuk's team who had
primarily helped when examining the
early cell divisions those that were
leading to necrosis and causing test
subjects to produce too much excessive
genetic material Alena had made a
startling Discovery and immediately
brought it to Dr zukal in a distraught
show of panic the cell samples they had
used to test their serum were now
gaining mass seemingly from nowhere just
like the earlier experiments the effects
were working almost too well causing an
overabundance of cellular regeneration
to the point where the cells couldn't
stop producing masses of waste genetic
material when zukal brought Alena's
findings to doctors ssard and one jury T
finko the project heads assigned by
division P they were quick to disregard
it as an error determining to press on
with the project to meet their deadline
over the course of the following weeks
up to late November zukal was trying to
determine what was causing this change
it was clear that unless he and Elena
could resolve the issues with the serum
subject x16 would be a total failure but
time was running out with the superiors
at Gru division p and the Kremlin
expecting results by early December
under untold amounts of pressure and
subsequent stress Dr paval zukal found
himself losing time unable to sleep to
the point where he was drifting off
whenever he was on the verge of a breakr
by the end Elena was the only member of
the team trying to help him methodically
figure out what had gone wrong the
deadline for the project arrived on
December 2nd
1972 paval didn't sleep all night
leading up to it knowing he would have
to present a functioning super soldier
to GRU division p in the best case he
was risking being accused of negligent
failure forced to restart the project
from scratch making his months of hard
work redundant but worst case scenario
zukal could be charged with treason for
having not completed the task he was
selected for on the 2nd of December he
wrote I really don't know which is
better tomorrow is a Day Too nobody
knows if Dr paval zukal lived to see
that tomorrow his final diary entry was
made on the day SCP 2102 was born for
months the SCP Foundation had operatives
in embedded within the Czechoslovakian
government as part of innumerable Cold
War Espionage Gathering efforts during
that time their agents had gathered
enough intelligence to make the
foundation aware of a GRU division P
Project based at The Institute of
experimental medicine and that the
scientists there were looking to unlock
the secret of Rapid cellular
regeneration someone possibly even one
of zuk's team had managed to infiltrate
the project and had leaked documents to
the SCP Foundation explaining what was
going on in Czechoslovakia the plan was
that the foundation would move in in
secret of course to extract and contain
test subject x16 in January of
1973 that day would never come to
fruition though on the 2nd of December
only a month before they had planned to
act the foundation became aware of a
catastrophe occurring at The Institute
of experimental medicine one of their
agents in Czechoslovakia alerted them to
a disturbance that had caused civilians
and scientists alike to run from The
Institute in fear for their lives
something had gotten loose and the
foundation had to act fast luckily a
reconnaissance team was stationed in
Eastern Europe members of various mobile
task forces who had been spying on Gru
division p and the rest of the USSR
moving quickly the Recon team was
deployed to Czechoslovakia led by a
field commander named Merck they were
given the objective to determine the
cause of the situation and if possible
recover its anomalous Source America and
the Recon team arrived on site at the
institute's grounds the entrance to the
bunker which had been housing the
project was left wide open with not a
soul in sight as the team progressed
further Merrick couldn't help but notice
a pungent smell permeating the labs and
offices that they passed Foundation
command urged their operatives to
proceed cautiously and recover any
paperwork they could among the
logistical documents was a diary
belonging to one of the scientists
although the name paval zukal on the
cover was no longer legible forever were
lost the further he and the other MTF
agents progressed the worse the smell
got they located an elevator deciding to
take it down to the lower levels of the
bunker one by one the team filed in
merri radio in command command any
seismic activity in the area he asked uh
not that we know of Mer came the
foundation's reply why I uh I think I
just felt something move down there the
elevator had barely descended a foot
before it hit something stopping in an
instant as mer tried once again to
contact Foundation command that same
something came tearing through the
elevator floor over the radio the SCP
Foundation were treated to a cacophony
of screeching tearing metal along with
the screams of their own men what
Merrick and his team had encountered may
have once spin a man perhaps someone
subjected to Cruelty and torture but now
all they saw was an amorphous flushing
Mass immediately the Recon team opened
fire engaging what they assumed was a
raging monster it probably never
occurred occurred to them that they
might have just wanted to be free after
years of imprisonment followed by months
of horrendous experiments minutes later
mer was able to get in contact with
command again locked in a heated battle
with the entity but every round fired
every shot their guns landed nothing was
having any effect whenever Merck dealt
damage to the creature part of it seemed
to grow faster and faster each time
their guns were useless unable to stop
the expanding monstrous test subject
even grenades thrown by the MTF
operatives causing multiple explosions
did little to stop the entity in its
tracks listening in over the radio
knowing they had few options left the
SCP Foundation dispatched a pair of f4
Phantoms long-range supersonic fighter
jets equipped with a payload of m47 A1
Napal incendiary bombs with Merck and
his men almost on the ropes command
issued an order to retreat they fled the
bunker only to feel the ground shake
beneath their feet the monster had
breathed reached the top soil still
coming after them Jones one of the
foundation's agents was Pulled Under the
encroaching shapeless Mass crushed to
death as it continued its Pursuit
utterly horrified at the sight and speed
of the creature Merck started begging
command over the radio to get its
fighter jets to the scene 6 minutes
later the sound of twin turbine engines
shot through the air followed by the
whistle of bombs caring down towards the
ground in a second Merrick his team and
the creature were engulfed in a fiery
explosion the heat proving enough to
cauterize the fleshy Abominations
expanding tissue ever since December
1972 The Entity now designated as SCP
2102 has been housed at site 122
contained by the SCP Foundation they
keep it in a modified cell restrained at
all times with its hands and feet and
padded sleeves this is done in order to
prevent the risk of injury either
accidental or intentional given both SCP
2102 anomalous properties and it
self-destructive Tendencies its body is
covered in scars both from its previous
Escape attempts back when it was known
as subject x16 and from burns from the
F4 Phantoms Napal payload these
particular injuries seared the entity's
ears mouth and eyes closed rendering it
deaf mute and blind if SCP 2102 ever
suffers any form of external injury its
anomalous properties will trigger the
creature as you might have guessed
possessed an advanced form of cellular
healing able to regenerate from all
wounds inflicted on it however the
process was never perfected it still
works too well so well that SCP 2102
cells don't know when to stop instead
they continue producing bodily tissue
expanding its mass into every available
space without a halt the process can be
slowed if an obstacle is introduced
boxing in the exponentially growing
tissue however any object or person in
its path is eventually crushed under the
mounting pressure pressure at present
the foundation still has no idea how
much SCP 2102 tissue could expand
potentially even posing a risk to the
entire world if left unchecked there is
only one Surefire way to stop the
creature's healing it can only be halted
by cauterizing the open wound with
intense heat it's literally a Surefire
solution SCP 2102 is a result of the
good Dr zuk's work combined with his and
Gru division P's willingness to put a
side their morality they didn't create
an undying regenerating super soldier
for the USSR as they had intended
instead all they accomplished was
turning a tortured man into a monster an
Abomination endlessly tormented by the
experiments performed on him not quite
as useful on the battlefield is it the
war that ended the world started on
October 9th
1971 tensions had been brewing for years
between America and the Soviet Union and
even though people had done their best
to keep a sense of normaly everyone was
wondering when the cold war that had
been brewing for the past 30 years would
boil over there were those who had been
preparing for it for years While others
assumed that it would never amount to
anything neither Nation wanted to make
the first nuclear strike and even if
that happened the engineers would come
out of their underground cities to
intervene but nobody knew for sure if
the two World superpowers could ever
come to an agreement or if it would all
end in total Destruction October 9th was
the day that question was finally
answered the first American nuclear
warhead detonated over the Gulf of
Finland only a few miles away from the
city of Leningrad where people were
going about their day blissfully unaware
of the destruction that was about to
befall them first came a city-wide
blackout as the power grid was bombarded
with a huge surge of radiation that
caused bulbs to blow and wires to glow
like they'd been struck by lightning
there was barely any time to react
before the next wave hit a white hot
flash so bright that many of those who
couldn't get to cover were blinded the
third Wave by far the most destructive
was the force of the explosion itself
like a powerful burning wind it swept
through the city breaking Windows
knocking over street lights ripping the
leaves off trees and bathing every car
building and person with Ash people are
trapped under the debris as some of the
City's older less well-maintained
buildings come crumbling down even
though the Soviet government had been
preparing for this day to come and the
Russian people had been put through
mandatory safety drills no amount of
practice or planning could have prepared
them for the real thing the streets
erupted into chaos cars were crashing
into buildings either because their
drivers had been Blinded By the Light of
the distant explosion or because the
initial wave of radiation had shorted
their batteries people nearly trampled
each other trying to get to underground
sh shelters as police and military tried
to yell directions over the cacophony
among the crowd a family desperately
tried to stay together Arena and Nikolai
bellat held tight to their children
Alexi and Tatiana the whole family was
still in their pajamas and barely had
time to get their shoes on before they
started rushing towards the
neighborhood's designated underground
bunker Arena had Tatiana who was only to
clutch tight to her chest and Nikolai
tried his best to keep 10-year-old
Alexis's eyes shielded as they walked
past the dead bodies of people who were
once their friends and neighbors it will
be all right soon son Nikolai said as
much as to try and convince himself as
his son We're Going Underground just
like in the safety Thrills Alexi nodded
solemnly and kept his Gaz Straight Ahead
they were almost at the end of the
street when just above the sounds of Aid
sirens and screaming people Alexi heard
a familiar voice Alexi Alexi the boy
looked down to see his teacher Mr Petro
trapped in the wreckage of his car he
must have been driving to work when the
bomb struck father stop Alexi yelled
tugging at his father's shirt sleeve
that's my teacher we have to help him or
he won't make it to the shelter the
soldiers will help him once everyone
else is in said Nikolai Alexi didn't
listen he wriggled free of his father's
grip and ran to where his teacher lay
pinned under the wrecked vehicle Nikolai
was calling after him and though Arena
wanted to wait for Alexi to come back
she was swept up in the tide of people
and separated from her husband Mr Petro
was crying thanking Alexi for coming to
his Aid as Alexi got closer he saw there
was blood pooling out from under the
wreck it seemed if Mr Petro were going
to make it out his legs would likely be
badly damaged Alexi tried to lift the
car himself but even though he was
strong for his age he was still only a
child a soldier had been helping people
into the bomb shelter stopped what he
was doing and ran over to Alexi Hey kid
the soldier shouted leave him alone and
go back to your family you're going to
hurt yourself Alexi kicked and struggled
Against The Soldier's grip as he was
dragged back into the line with his
family but he's in trouble Alexi cried
it's not your job to save him his father
scolded as he took his hand and led him
down the stairs where they would rejoin
his mother and sister as Alexi and his
father descended into the tunnels Alexi
heard a gunshot from the street above
though he would survive long after that
day he never saw his teacher Mr Petro
again he never asked his father bother
about what happened the batro family was
reunited in the underground shelter
which had once been an underground train
station Tatiana had started crying and
Nikolai tried desperately to quiet her
Arena hugged her son so tight he felt
she might squeeze the life out of him
they were packed in with a dozen other
families some they knew and others who
were strangers Alexi recognized some of
the other children from school and saw
that some were there without their
parents while they were in the station a
soldier addressed the group and
explained what would happen next the
train station was to serve as their
temporary shelter until the proper
negotiations were made with the
engineers as per a treaty that had been
written and signed after the second
world war the engineers had agreed to
open the borders of their underground
civilization to humans fleeing from a
crisis above ground once the government
had made a decision the survivors were
to be taken deep underground where they
would live until the war was over above
ground the Soviet Union began dealing
with the Fallout of the initial attack
it was clear that America could no
longer be dealt with reasonably if they
were willing to bomb one of the ussr's
biggest cities though the bombing had
cut Communications between Leningrad and
Moscow eventually contact was
reestablished and the Army was able to
radio the Kremlin with a full report on
the damage Leningrad was in ruin with
over a third of the population dead or
otherwise too wounded to move
underground those who had made it
underground were receiving treatment
from everything from broken bones and
blindness to radiation poisoning in a
word it was chaos Russian Parliament was
quick and ruthless in their decision to
strike back on October 12th secretary
breev authorized nuclear missiles to be
launched at both New York City and
Washington DC Millions were killed and
just like in Russia the survivors
retreated underground America didn't go
down without a fight though and launched
another missile attack this time at
Moscow
it wasn't long before both countries
allies were involved in the conflict as
well with missile strikes coming from
France China North Korea Germany and the
United Kingdom within a month the
surface of the Earth was dangerously
irradiated and any humans who were still
living had retreated underground but
though the world had ended the war had
not Alexi batro and his family struggled
to adjust to their new life underground
though the engineers were intelligent
and humanlike there were world was so
different from the world Alexi had lived
in for the first 10 years of his life he
barely ever saw them the engineers were
nocturnal sleeping while an artificial
sun nourished the genetically engineered
plants that grew around the city but
anytime he tried to ask questions about
them he was met with hushed Silence by
the adults the engineers were spoken of
in hushed almost reverent tones they
were the beings that saved Humanity yes
but they had also helped build the
weapons that led to the war in the first
place Alexi barely had any time to
settle into this new life before what
remained of the Russian army started
looking for new recruits reports had
come in from an above ground Scout that
the Americans were working on a new type
of armor that could fully Shield the
wearer against radiation and the Soviets
could not afford to be outmatched when
their army was still recovering from
multiple nuclear attacks but the Army
wasn't asking for able-bodied adult men
to enlist they were looking for children
children we can't possibly send our son
to war Arena said arguments at the
dinner table had become common in the
batro family he would not be going to
war Nikolai argued not until their new
anti-radiation technology is perfected
he won't be ready until he's an adult
how do you know that what they're making
in those labs won't kill him Arena said
do we really want to trust these
underground Devils with our son how much
do we really know about the engineers
anyway they could have let us all burn
on this surface Nikolai said but they
didn't I think we should trust them I
want to go said Alexi I should some of
my friends have already enlisted both of
his parents were stunned but it made
sense to Alexi he wanted the war to be
over and he wanted to leave the
underground city but most importantly he
wanted to know if anyone was still alive
on the surface if there was even a
sliver of chance that it could be
habitable again he wanted to find out
out after much discussion Arena and
Nikolai agreed it was what was best for
the future of Russia and ultimately the
future of the human race Alexis's
parents delivered him to the office of
Army Recruitment and he was taken by a
man named Commander vov to a specialized
research facility this was when Alexi
met an engineer for the first time the
engineer was tall and hairy like a bear
walking on its back legs but with face
and hands more like a humans it was
overseen a group of humans and other
Engineers as they tinkered with machines
that Alexi couldn't even begin to guess
the purpose of do not be frightened Lexi
Commander vov said they're going to
explain the procedure to you before you
have to agree to anything the engineer
looked the boy over then held up a jar
containing something that looked like an
insect's exoskeleton it was green the
same shade as the ussr's army uniforms
this is our new bioorganic a prototype
the engineer said we can only graph it
onto you while you are still growing it
must grow with you starting on your back
then moving to your limbs then your head
Alexi was frightened by the idea but
didn't want to seem weak he wanted to
make sure his father would be proud of
him he was taken into surgery where the
team of Engineers and human doctors
grafted the plate of bioorganic armor
onto his spine once the Sur was over he
was wheeled into a recovery room where
he was fed a simple meal alongside all
of his friends and classmates they had
all gone through the same procedure over
the next 8 years Alexi and his comrades
went through the painful process of
growing their exoskeleton like the
engineer had said it grew with them but
the growth happened in painful spurts
rather than gradually the worst thing
about the armor was that it couldn't be
removed but it gave them many advantages
to normal soldiers as well once it
covered Alexis's legs he found he could
jump higher and run farther than any
human normally could when it grew over
his arms it gave him increased strength
by the time he was 18 it had covered his
head giving it a fly-like appearance but
also granting him stereoscopic vision
and the ability to hear radio
Transmissions without the need for any
other communication device during this
time he and the other boys were trained
by Commander vov learning how to use the
powers granted to them by their
exoskeletons for combat when they were
deemed ready they were all outfitted
with shoulder cannons Supply packs and
guns all of which were also bioorganic
and were surgically attached it had been
eight long years since the end of the
world and Alexi was now able to set foot
back on the surface the world he
returned to was almost unrecognizable
there were no signs of life outside of
weeds and Vines overtaking the
irradiated ruins of of buildings within
the first hour of returning to the
surface Alexi gave up any hope of
finding survivors he heard volkov's
voice barking orders through the suit
there was no time to reminisce about the
past the soldiers had a job to do
welcome back comrade the case of SCP
2273 also known as major Alexi batro has
sparked your imagination and you need to
know more but even if you're not
familiar with the major his story all
you need to know is that it's one of War
tragedy and Alternate Dimensions he
first appeared in the town of Danner
Wisconsin on the 13th of October
1989 during an unprecedented seismic
event when he was first discovered the
foundation researchers assumed that he
was an extraterrestrial being on account
of his Advanced organic exoskeleton in a
surprising move for such an imposing
creature batro gave himself up to
Foundation agents without a fight major
batro was then impounded in Foundation
containment site 17 where he was
interrogated thoroughly over a series of
interviews the foundation ascertained
that batov came from an alternate
timeline where Russia and the US are
locked in a so-called war to end the
world thanks to Advanced military
technology given to them by SCP 1000
bellatv had nearly escaped execution at
the hands of American soldiers and
appeared in our timeline now he is a
prisoner of the advanced suit that
formerly kept him alive but his story
isn't over The Last Remnant of a cold
war turned hot has plenty left to teach
us something that you need to understand
about the SCP Foundation before we go
any further is that it doesn't only
exist in every nation across the globe
it also exists in every Splinter reality
across the Multiverse and these Splinter
realities offer a countless multitude of
tales of different places different
people and different times today's tale
concerns major bov's future in a
universe where the secrecy of the
foundation is broken and the anomalous
world needs to find a way to fit in with
our own the year was 2018 like many
humanoid anomalies that the foundation
was holding in this timeline bellatv was
released from containment he was no
longer an SCP he was now a mere Person
of Interest free to move around as he
pleased but this didn't mean bellatv was
about to enjoy a quiet life on easy
street he was still an interdimensional
Refugee from a broken alternate World
thankfully there was a certain group
willing to help the Mana charitable
Foundation this anomalous charity has
been involved in a number of strange
cases investigated by the foundation
before and now they were going to lend a
hand to Major bellatv thanks to their
anomaly reintegration project Mana was
able to transport bellatv back to his
home of vrad in Russia there he became
something of a national celebrity making
headlines across the country sitting
down for interviews on every Russian
talk show and even being offered book
deals but as a former military man
bellatv was eager to return to
government life and run for a government
position however this ambition didn't go
very far bellatv was rejected by all the
government bodies he applied to even
Vladimir Putin wasn't eccentric enough
to want an insectoid cyborg from another
dimension in his cabinet bellatv endured
a rough 2 years in VRA he was treated
more like a sideshow freak than a human
being people didn't want to rent
apartments to him and he was never able
to find permanent employment even
entry-level jobs rejected him nobody
wanted to get food served to them by
what looked to be a 7ot monster and he
seemed equally ill suited to help
Russian women find the right perfume in
department stores in April of 2020
bellatv had finally had enough he
contacted the Mana charitable Foundation
once again and asked to be relocated
they told him that some religious
institutions in the area including the
Eastern Clockwork Orthodox Church were
accepting and housing anomalous refugees
not long after this batro truly fell off
of the SCP foundation's radar but one
former Foundation operative was well
aware of major bellator's fate it's 2021
Dr Friedrich the site 17 anomaly
psychologist who' conducted all the
initial interviews with batov all the
way back in 1989 started receiving
letters from him there was no indication
as to his true location and they
appeared to have been handled by a Mana
charitable Foundation mail carrier in
Russia but Dr friederick was happy to
hear from an old friend nonetheless due
to a career of working near highly
radioactive anomalies like bellatv Dr
Friedrich was suffering from terminal
lymphoma it seemed almost like an act of
Divine Providence that bov's letters
would come to him so close to the end
the two began a correspondence and it
was only after Dr Frederick's eventual
death that the letters came to the SCP
foundation's attention it was from this
final correspondence that the foundation
was able to answer the big question
whatever happened to Major Alexi batov
in his first letter to Dr Fredick batro
thanked him profusely he knew that Dr
friedi had been a crucial part of him
gaining freedom from the foundation and
credited the therapeutic techniques
taught to him by Dr friederick with
keeping him alive
and sane to this day batov expressed a
mix of Amazement at this Brave New World
and a sense of profound weariness as a
man eternally locked into a weapon of
War he felt unsuited to a world in
peacetime he almost missed the scorched
irradiated Russia of his home Dimension
but most of all he missed site 17 he
missed Dr friederick he missed some of
his fellow anomalies like SCP 507 the
teleporting man and SCP 163 the
spacecraft he even missed the Simplicity
of being contained he hoped that Dr
friederick would write back in his
second letter batro began detailing his
experience with the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodox Church despite growing up in a
highly atheistic communist environment
batro became enamored with the ways of
the church he found them to be highly
accepting of him in spite of his
unfortunate circumstances they displayed
a freedom in their faith that bellatv
had never encountered before and he was
eager to be part of it with the help of
Dr friederick batov was also sending
letters to some of his fellow freed
anomalies he signed off by saying that
he had even started praying something
he'd never considered before the next
letter sent in 2027 struck a much more
somber tone he was sent shortly after
batro discovered Dr Frederick's
diagnosis he wanted to return and see
the doctor one more time but the Mana
charitable Foundation wouldn't allow him
to return to site 17 believing he had
been abused during his time there belov
gave Frederick his prayers and well-
wishes and asked for a number through
which he could contct his ailing old
friend by the time the next letter
arrived in 2034 batro had become a
fully-fledged member of the Eastern
Clockwork Orthodox Church he referred to
the other Monks at the monastery as his
brothers and sisters he seemed to have
finally found a true home there and the
others fondly referred to him by the
nickname Father Anvil but the true part
of the letter is bov's deep concern for
Dr Frederick's Health notably in this
letter he often refers to Dr friedi by
his first name Thomas as though to
emphasize the urgency of the message
after the deaths of several of the
anomalies that belov considered friends
he stated that he couldn't handle losing
anyone else his letter ends with a
poignant passage you may be unmarried Dr
friederick but you are not unloved you
have to be strong for me you have to be
strong for yourself if you're ever
worried that that you cannot find the
strength to continue think of the garden
you'll plant this spring I'd like to
share gardening photos with you again
not many of my brothers and sisters here
appreciate the simple beauty of a flower
bed or the effort that goes into growing
a patch of vegetables it's a beauty I'd
like to continue to share trust in the
power of Our Lord Thomas and Trust in
the power of modern medicine God is
smiling on you please be strong with
love and prayers Alexi batro this letter
arrived on the 15th of February 2034
sadly Dr friederick had already passed
away 4 days earlier he never got to see
Alexis's final letter and it truly was
his final letter with nobody left for
him in the world major bellat trov
stopped sending any correspondents what
we know about the final years of Bell's
life all comes from a few scattered
journal entries translated from Russian
after his passing they provide clues as
to the kind of life he lived during the
29 years the foundation could not
account for for his whereabouts and his
actions the first entry written on
January 7th 2035 paints a grim picture
of batro feeling broken and isolated in
the monastery he wrote today is the day
that our Monastery celebrates the birth
of our Lord however I feel no desire to
celebrate all of my friends in this
world are dead my brothers and sisters
are partaking in some celebration
outside my dormatory all of their
required ceremonies are complete neither
they nor whatever is happening out there
will lighten my mood batov also wrote
about losing the Comfort he once had in
his faith and his doubts about whether
he would be able to recapture that
Comfort but he had survived greater
traumas than this and he would continue
to press on as the months turned to
years and the years turned to decades
batro climbed through the ranks of the
monastery seeing as the Eastern
Clockwork Orthodox Church practically
worshiped the concepts of
industrialization and mechanization the
fact that bellatv was permanently
encased in a biomechanical exoskeleton
probably made him seem even more Pious
to his holy Brethren the final piece of
evidence collected by the foundation
Into The Life and Times of Alexi batov
came just over 20 years later in a final
address written to comfort his followers
in preparation for his own death batro
recounted the details of his own life
being born into a world of fire death
and mushroom clouds then his life being
suddenly saved by forces Beyond his
control only to place him into
containment for almost 30 years it was
only after accepting the teachings of
the church and accepting the Clockwork
Goddess that he felt he was truly free
from his past in this final note batro
lay out some of the teachings of his new
religion the belief in a great
mechanized goddess who planned all of
reality according to batov everything in
her design fits together perfectly like
cogs in a machine turning and twisting
in Unison to create an ideal world he
hoped to be forgiven for the many
violent sins he committed in his
military life and that his contributions
to this new world were valuable at the
very end of his address batov wrote I do
not believe that my time in this world
is much longer brothers and sisters when
my time of judgment comes do not mourn
me I would rather you remember these
words the goddess is most pleased with
those who seek kind nonviolent
resolution to their problems because a
machine whose gears grind against each
other is a machine that cannot work see
truth but also compassion the words are
only words seek out truth within them
God bless you all father Anvil a month
after authoring this statement records
indicate that Alexi belatra was found
dead in his room having passed away
peacefully in his sleep from natural
causes he lived A Warrior's life but
died a humble priest's death the true
tragedy in The Strange Life of major
Alexi bellatv is how little Choice he
had in his circumstances but thanks to
this tale we know he did what he could
with the life he was given his remains
lay within the graveyard at the Eastern
Clockwork Orthodoxy Monastery where he
spent the last years of his life with a
life as difficult as his own we can only
imagine he's glad to finally rest there
is something inherently unnerving about
the sight of someone wearing a gas mask
maybe it's the wide soulless Port holes
where a person's eyes should be or the
huge round filter extruding from their
face that makes them look like something
inhuman it could also be the fact that
if ever you see someone wearing a gas
mask you may be surrounded by poisonous
gas and if you're not wearing one
yourself someone else's gas mask may be
the last thing you ever see whatever the
reason you might be wondering why we're
talking so much about gas masks well
that's because you're about to meet SCP
1499 which is as you might have already
guessed an anomalous gas mask for all
you military history Buffs out there SCP
14499 is specifically a Soviet gp5 gas
mask these were produced between 1962
and 1990 as a way to protect the wearer
from The Fallout of a nuclear blast back
then during the cold War an atomic
conflict between the United States and
the USSR that's Russia was a constant
threat and so these masks were sent to
most of the Fallout shelters in the
Soviet Union while the gp5 masks could
survive in all weather and protect
against radioactive substances for a
Time some of their filters contained a
number of harmful chemicals like lead
and asbestos the fact that these gas
masks were airtight would mean that
somebody could end up inhaling these
toxic chemicals while trying to protect
themselves from nuclear fallout if you
look up the definition of irony in the
dictionary you may see a picture of one
of these gas masks sitting right next to
it and if you think that sounds bad just
wait until you hear what sets SCP 1499
apart from the rest upon first
inspection The Mask still seems to
perform its original function the filter
works properly and the airtight seal is
still formed when placed upon somebody's
head however when warn by someone the
anomalous effects of SCP 1499 will also
activate while it doesn't fuse to the
wearer's face and turns them into a
hysterical zombie chillingly asking for
their mommy the gas mask does cause
Anyone who puts it on to completely
disappear from view now it's worth
noting that this isn't a gas mask that
grants its user the power of
invisibility if that was the case this
anomalous item may actually be desirable
SCP 1499 instead causes a person to
physically vanish
as in they are no longer detectable at
all subjects that have worn SCP 1499
report that they don't feel any
sensation of moving they simply put the
mask on and end up well we'll get to
where it is they go you see through
testing the SCP foundation's researchers
were able to determine that giving
someone a two-way radio before they put
SCP 1499 on means that they can still be
contacted after they vanish and it's
through the these radios that the
foundation discovered where the mask
wearers go during testing subjects have
reportedly found themselves in a strange
alternate Dimension after putting on SCP
1499 it has been described as a dark
environment inhospitable Barren and
filled with tall black tower-like
structures you would think being
unceremoniously transported to another
dimension by a gas mask would be bad
enough just wait until you meet the
locals according to a number of test
subjects a group of humanoid entities
inhabit this Dimension designated as SCP
1499-1 these creatures are taller than
the average person completely nude and
covered from head to toe in a coat of a
dark viscous substance unlike anything
found in our Dimension these SCP 1499-1
entities also have been described as
having too many mouths and a large
number of eyes covering their bodies
from the sound of it the whole place
makes the upside down from stranger
things sound like a pleasant destination
for a family vacation for the record the
reason we say according to a number of
test subjects is that there has never
been any photographic or video evidence
of this place and the creatures that
inhabited all that we have gathered to
date has come strictly from firsthand
descriptions of those experiencing the
anomalous effects of SCP
1499 luckily anyone that puts on scp1
1499 and finds themselves in the this
place has a very quick and easy Escape
Route should a subject encounter any
danger in this dark inhospitable
dimension then taking the gas mask off
will drop them right back into our own
plane of existence upon arriving back
they will not have moved from the spot
they were standing in when they first
disappeared but it is unknown exactly
how the gas mask is able to return them
or indeed how it can send someone to an
entirely different dimension at all so a
gateway to another dimension that's what
the mask is the foundation has been
running tests on SCP 1499 since they
first acquired it at first using d-class
Personnel the first test involving SCP
1499 saw a d-class d 6739 3 told to put
on the mask when she did she found
herself transported inside a building
that was constructed from an unknown
black substance d67 393 surveyed the
room she was in for a few seconds only
to hear something moving close by the
sound caused her to panic and she
wretched the gas mask off her face
returning to the test chamber given that
there was now a risk of losing SCP 1499
the foundation moved forward with tests
involving trained agents instead of
d-class personnel following this the
next test involved an agent C putting on
the mask and like the d-class before him
he found himself in the same dark room
but instead of taking off SCP 1499 at
the first sign of trouble this agent
explored his surroundings agency was
able to descend the building to a
reasonable degree until he heard sounds
coming from the floor below after hiding
himself agency witnessed the very first
sighting of the SCP 1499-1 creatures
remaining undetected and then safely
removing the mask when the creatures had
passed another agent known as agent U
was selected for an SCP 1499 test chosen
especially for her extensive training in
and stealth like those before her she
put on the gas mask instantly she found
herself in the place where her
predecessor had left off and continued
the exploration of the building
detecting movement from the floors above
agent U exited the building and spotted
a number of SCP 1499-1 instances the
creatures were mulling aimlessly around
each sporting their own unique mutations
occasionally uttering low grading Noises
by now if they were still using DCL
classes is they probably would have lost
the mask and the people wearing it a 100
times over never get a d-class to do a
field agent's job making her way past
more of the tall dark structures the
agent followed and observed a group of
four creatures a fifth approach them
prompting one from the group to step
forward as agent you watched these SCP
1499-1 creatures began violently
assaulting each other until she too
pulled the gas mask off and returned to
the foundation shortly afterward one
final agent Agent K was sent into this
alternate Dimension this was less of a
test more a mission with the purposes of
reconnaissance to give the foundation a
better clearer idea of what the
environment was like and to possibly
even make contact with the SCP 1499-1
and understand them better however the
outcome that followed could not have
been worse Agent K appeared in the other
dimension between two of the black
structures the lighting made it
difficult to see much of the environment
around him but he remarked that the
buildings resembled tall spires
constructed out of hard rock as was the
ground beneath him after a few short
minutes he soon spotted a group of SCP
1499-1 entering a larger structure an
elaborate building with a number of
towers and spikes on it as well as what
appeared to be blood approaching the
building with caution Agent K located a
small secluded side entrance away from
the larger front door as quietly as he
could he made his way inside the sounds
of grinding filled the air from all
around him as Agent K saw a huge group
of the mutated humanoid creatures each
one had their mouth wide open all of
their mouths wide open making a chorus
of grating sounds the entities were
according to case's description all
facing towards one of the SCP 1499-1
that was standing on a platform in front
of them with a number of B iodes around
it this creature seemed to be leading an
odd ritual and began to cut open its own
torso wormlike creatures Spilled Out of
the open womb and a beam of light
followed projecting out of the entity's
chest Agent K realized that this light
was some form of portal another worm
like the kind that had come out of the
ritual Leader's chest began to appear in
the portal deciding to act Agent K
dashed out from his hiding place opening
fire at the creatures all around him he
reached for something glowing in the the
lead entity's chest which he thought was
bringing the worm creature through the
portal grabbing it Agent K pulled off
the gas mask and found himself back at
the foundation holding a human heart but
it doesn't end there at the exact same
time on the exact same date a man
attacked the Cathedral of Christ the
savior in Moscow Russia during the
church's morning Services the gunman
entered dressed in a suit with a gas
mask over his face and proceeded to
shoot 10 civilians six were killed three
left in critical condition including the
church's chanter however the worst
occurred to the priest performing the
service the attacker ran to the front of
the cathedral producing a knife which he
used to cut open the priest's chest and
remove his heart then just as quickly as
he had appeared the as salent vanished
before the eyes of multiple Witnesses
and Moscow police were unable to find
any trace of the man officially the
cathedral was attacked by Nikolai orov
undercover foundation operatives in side
Russia's media and military have spread
this cover story of a violent man who
acted alone in his attack on the church
meanwhile the SCP Foundation is keeping
Agent K detained questioning him about
his involvement in the incident
according to him everything happened
exactly as he described it no church no
priest just him wearing SCP 1499 and
surrounded by the creatures the audio
recordings taken from his exploration
Mission also seem to align with this
story but that still doesn't explain how
another figure in a gas mask appeared in
Moscow and claimed the lives of multiple
churchgoers not only that but
dispatching them in the exact same way
Agent K dealt with the SCP 1499-1
creatures the only possible explanation
was that agent K was the perpetrator
even if in his mind he was still telling
the truth hoping to avoid another
incident the 05 Council has suspended
all further testing with SCP 14499
Agent K has been scheduled to undergo a
psychological evaluation believing the
creature he saw being summoned had to be
stopped at all costs the other agents
and the d-class involved in earlier
testing are all being brought in for
questioning as well it is still unknown
what the anomalous effect of SCP 1499
truly is is it actually capable of
transporting someone to another
dimension or does it give a person
hallucinations that make them think
they're gallivanting off in dimension X
while while they're actually walking up
to a church about to do something
Unthinkable with testing suspended we
may never know but it leaves us with an
important message think carefully about
everything you do because what you think
you can see doesn't always reflect
what's really there it has long been the
mission of the SCP Foundation to secure
and contain any anomalies they encounter
all to protect the safety of the human
race sometimes containing an SCP is a
trivial task as simple as guarding a
room or keeping an eye on an artifact
with strange but mostly harmless
properties other times though anomalies
require a considerable number of the
foundation's personnel and resources to
keep them under control this latter
category commonly includes some of the
most dangerous creatures and entities
that the SCP Foundation keeps under lock
and key however while it might be only
in very rare cases every so often an SCP
comes along with its very own built-in
method of containment this can often be
the result of someone encountering an
anomaly and discovering the perfect way
of imprisoning it before the SCP
Foundation comes along and steals all
the credit undoubtedly this makes the
job of securing an anomaly all the
easier for the foundation's staff after
all someone else has already done the
hard part of the job for them or rather
it would make things easier if only the
foundation's own researchers chose not
to interfere and could leave a deadly
threat kept safely in its box without
trying to find out what makes it tick
SCP 5001 is in some ways a reminder that
some things are best left alone but it
is also a grave warning not to tamper
with that which you do not understand
both of these lessons would soon be
imparted on the SCP Foundation buried 60
km below the ground in Northern Russia
is SCP 5001 a 53 km wide structure it is
an enormous biomechanical machine but to
the untrained eye there is nothing
anomalous about the object and according
to the foundation's findings this is
indeed the case there is nothing
inherently anomalous about the structure
itself but there are a number of
characteristics that seem to suggest it
is in some way connected to anomalous
phenomena for one there is the sheer
scale of the structure and then there's
the records that were uncovered about
SCP 5001 which appear to have been
monitoring and tracking its status
perhaps whoever constructed it or
discovered it kept a record as they
observed the structure nothing too out
of the ordinary about that but what's
strange is that these date back to
11,000 BC and yet Were Somehow made with
modern systems of measurement and other
weirder documents have been recovered
from inside of SCP 5001 records written
in languages from all over the world and
even some in languages lost to time
among them are papers in Phoenician
ancient Hebrew both ancient and modern
greek latin anglosaxon along with modern
Russian English and Mandarin some of
these documents are even written in
languages that the SCP foundation's top
researchers are yet to properly identify
the explanation for all this would seem
obvious wouldn't it writing in both
ancient and contemporary languages
records that date all the way back to
the last of the prehistoric era it all
seems to point in a certain direction
somehow SCP 5001 has a link to time
travel perhaps it was even a hub for a
group of Time Travelers right wrong the
foundation already thought that this
might be the case and checked for any
signs of temporal anomalies and yet they
found nothing no evidence to suggest
that there had ever been any time travel
near or using SC SCP
5001 there were no devices on site that
could affect time and no traces of any
residue or Fallout from a temporal
occurrence so what exactly does this
thing even do well we're afraid to say
the foundation researchers have been
stumped on the answer to that question
too and they are not the only ones
either way back in the ' 50s the Gru's
division P also had an interest in SCP
5001 for anyone who isn't already
acquainted with them they are one of the
SCP foundation's numerous groups of
Interest a list of organizations
corporations and agencies from around
the world who have also had dealings
with anomalies in the case of grup they
were originally a division of the
Russian army during the Cold War the
specialty of Gru division P was the
acquisition of anomalous objects and
entities in other words they were the
Soviet Union's very own SCP Foundation
in 1953 Gru division P was alerted to
abnormal seismic activity in a narrow
region of Northern Russia a team was
immediately sent in to investigate and
began attempting to take seismic
measurements of the area in question
during their various experiments and
tests Gru division P realized a
discrepancy in their readings again and
again they checked and double checked
their results only to discover that this
reading wasn't the result of faulty
equipment or even human error there was
something big nearby what they hadn't
yet realized was around 30 km away deep
underground was SCP 5001 immediately Gru
division P began drilling towards the
location of SCP 5001 but for years found
that they were unable to breach the
exterior of the structure defeated the
project was abandoned in
1955 however Soviet leader first
Secretary Kev seemed to have a vested
interest in gaining access to SCP 5001
as a result he privately funded the gru
division P operation allowing them to
continue their work in secret for a
number of years from 1959 until kushev
was disposed used in
1964 of course this was all during the
height of the Cold War but by the late
1960s international relations between
the Soviet Union and the United States
of America were starting to ease thanks
to the relaxing tensions a contract was
introduced allowing the two Nations
secret organizations to work together on
a number of operations involving
potentially dangerous anomalies this
meant that the SCP Foundation was
finally able to step in and contribute
to the gru division P project concerning
SCP 5001 their first task actually
getting inside the Subterranean
structure naturally given how
well-versed the foundation is in dealing
with anomalies they had ideas for how to
crack this nut by acquiring anomalous
technology from the global occult
Coalition another group of Interest as
well as experimental designs created by
one Dr Elijah rakma the SCP Foundation
were finally able to breach the
structure in
1971 from then until the dissolution of
the Soviet Union in 1991 the SCP
Foundation and Gru division P worked
together to conduct a number of studies
into the origin and purpose of SCP
5001 both organizations were curious as
to the technology the structure
possessed and attempts were even made to
recreate some of the devices found
within among this advanced technology
were ontological stabilizers also known
as Scranton reality anchors which are
located around SCP 51's inner chamber
these were designed to directly alter
the amount of Humes in a given area
what's a Hume well to keep it simple a
Hume is a measure of the reality around
us if it helps imagine reality as a pile
of sand now imagine that you remove a
single grain of sand from the pile
congratulations you just removed one
Hume from this reality taking one away
doesn't really do much but start
grabbing handfuls and the pile gets
smaller scattered less a pile and more a
light dusting of sand reality works the
same way take too much away and it
starts to lose whatever it was before
being able to alter the amount of Humes
in an area meant that these ontological
stabilizers could alter the strength of
reality itself even nullify the reality
bending properties of some anomalies in
theory an SCP with the power to
influence reality could be contained
using this technology the effects of
their abilities reduced significantly
although not negated entirely another
noteworthy piece of Technology uncovered
was code named Omega Omega was
discovered in an unmarked room on a
computer terminal that was connected to
every area of SCP 5001 by dozens of
cables the software itself was an
artificial intelligence construct a
computerized Consciousness that seemed
to serve the purpose of controlling the
various systems within SCP 5001 the
Omega seemed to work by providing an
answer whenever someone used a keyboard
to input a question the artificial
intelligence of appeared able to hold a
conversation but would refuse to give
any insight into when the SCP 5001
structure was built or what its purpose
was despite neither group knowing what
SCP 51's function was an agreement
between the SCP Foundation and Gru
division P was formed both organizations
shared the belief that Omega the
ontological stabilizers as well as the
other anomalous Technologies could never
under any circumstances be allowed to
fall into the Raw long hands they had a
pack to keep the knowledge of SCP 5001
and these devices strictly between
themselves however this agreement was
sadly not to last in the early '90s Gru
division P liquidated its assets and
disbanded a number of the Russian
division's highest ranking officers
stole the anomalous technology that the
organization had in its possession which
they then sold to Marshall Carter and
dark limited MC and dltd are yet another
of the SCP found foundation's groups of
Interest according to Foundation
intelligence Marshall Carter and dark
limited is a London based club that has
caused numerous problems for the
foundation over the years they have ties
to wealthy figures across the globe and
cater to the super rich clientele by
providing them with the most exclusive
expensive and rare experiences available
how do they do this by gathering the
anomalous items and auctioning them off
to the highest biders a number of Gru
division P operatives also joined Jo up
with the chaos Insurgency this is a
group of interest that consists of
personnel who previously worked for the
foundation but have since broken a away
to pursue their own Rogue agenda much
like a number of other groups of
Interest the Insurgency uses anomalies
and scps for their own benefit as well
as dabbling in a bit of arm stealing and
the selling of Highly classified
intelligence hey it's good to have a
diverse portfolio despite former members
of Gru division P seeking alternative
employment with some less than rep
utable groups the SCP Foundation still
managed to keep the existence and
location of SCP 5001 a closely guarded
secret however even with the structure
fully under their control their leading
researchers were still baffled as to
what exactly the purpose of the
underground structure was or rather that
was the case on December 30th 2019 an
explosion erupted in the Northeast
sector of SCP 5001 the cause of the
explosion was unknown but the damage
caused a tremendous and almost
catastrophic loss of power whether the
explosion had been triggered by one of
the many groups of Interest like the
former Gru division P or just a
Machinery malfunction it almost caused
the total Destruction of SCP 5001 what
would be so bad about that well remember
earlier when we said that every so often
an SCP comes along with its very own
built-in method of containment you see
it wasn't the structure or technology of
SCP 5001 that the foundation should have
been worried about it was the thing
inside of SCP
5001 just as some Foundation researchers
had long theorized SCP 5001 was a cage a
containment unit for its own anomalous
objects within something powerful enough
to alter reality right down to the Humes
hence the need for ontological
stabilizers to dampen its power and
Omega to keep the place running this
entity known either as SCP
51- or the devour was being held inside
SCP 5001 and when the structure was
damaged it was almost freed while there
was no data on SCP 51's computer system
about this being's appearance or the
extent of its anomalous Powers whoever
created SCP 5001 went to considerable
effort to keep the devour contained
viewing it as a threat to all of reality
and all that effort was almost undone
when the structure was damaged by the
explosion fortunately the SCP Foundation
was able to reestablish containment of
SCP
51- though at the cost of a tremendous
amount of lives when Personnel were
finally permitted to reenter SCP 5001 a
number of the structures core systems
had been damaged but it was still able
to perform its primary function and keep
the devour safely contained within as
Personnel entered the structure a
message appeared through the Omega
computer system that read hello my
children although you have grown
immensely since your earliest days you
have much room to grow your species
intellect is merely a bud with so much
potential your weapons are powerful your
medicine is supreme your engineering is
beautiful with proper guidance and care
you are sure to reach an elevated state
of being and transcend your bodies for
something more whole and perfect that is
why it pains me so dearly to request
that you leave this place immediately
you're studying in prob have almost
resulted in the end of all I have worked
towards to keep you alive if you comply
I guarantee that the Devourer will never
escape and your species will be free to
pursue the enlightenment of technology
for all eternity let this be my final
gift to you directly from the center of
my broken heart okay back up broken
heart interesting where have we heard
something like that before we'd hate to
jump to any conclusions but when one
hears about a being of great power
related to large and mysterious machines
and that word again broken all the
groups of interest that seem to be tied
into SCP 5001 and we neglected to
mention perhaps the most important of
all the Church of the broken God this
religious organization that reveres
industry and Technology over the
impurity of Flesh has been United in a
singular purpose rebuilding their deity
the broken God mechain whose body was
split apart in an attempt to preserve
the future of mankind perhaps the heart
of this great and ancient machine this
Devourer is actually the heart of
something else entirely though of course
there's only so much we can speculate
knowledge after all can sometimes be
like a flame it can light your way but
if you get too close you will inevitably
be burned if ever you're in doubt ask
the people devoured and assimilated by
the heart of meccan the last time it was
freed by the church if ever the heart
gets out again you'll certainly be with
them the SCP Foundation has come so far
their technology their knowledge their
vast resources all allow them to contain
some of the most powerful forces mankind
has ever seen and even some we haven't
but as SCP 5001 shows there is still
much that even the brightest researchers
at the foundation don't yet understand
and their drive to poke and prod the
unknown nearly led to the end of reality
as we know it perhaps one day we'll be
able to fully understand just what the
Devourer is and the ways that SCP 51
work to protect us from it but we're not
there yet and there's no guarantee that
we ever will be while the pursuit of
knowledge is always an admirable one
when it comes to SCP 5001 maybe the
foundation should have left well enough
alone SCP 3930 does not exist thanks for
watching now check out SCP the following
information is only known to seven
living people even those actively
guarding this anomaly will never know
this information every single person who
believes they are aware of the existence
of SCP 3930 has the potential to
increase its danger SCP 3930 has been
given the risk class critical the
highest possible risk class for an
anomaly meaning that individuals nearby
will invariably be exposed to acute
life-threatening harm and that these
effects cannot be mitigated you learn
about SCP 3930 at your own risk with the
knowledge that this awareness puts your
life at Hazard someday soon you may be
forced to make the ultimate sacrifice
for the good of all life and matter in
the universe that is why it is
imperative that you know one essential
thing SCP 3930 does not exist now with
that out of the way we have only only
one question for you can you hear the
screaming it was when Dr vasilev heard
the screaming that he and his ragtag
team of scientists knew it was already
over the year was 1971 and Dr vasilia's
team was stationed at a highly secretive
Soviet research Outpost near what would
later be established as the Russian town
of yusin within the Comey Republic as
far as Dr Vil was concerned they were
dead men already well that's not
entirely accurate to be dead is to be
something and the men that had once been
stationed with them but were here no
longer could not be considered something
at all their brush with the immensely
powerful and classified anomaly later
known as SCP 3930 had robbed them of
their very existence now Dr VV knew that
he and the few remaining men stationed
at the base with him would be next the
Soviet government had dispatched a
Detachment consisting of around 100
soldiers and scientists to investigate
the anomaly in the Comey Republic as far
as they could tell it appeared to occupy
a 1 km square area within a forest but
to say that it really occupied anything
would be a stretch and out of the over
100 men who had been dispatched now
scarcely 30 remain observation teams had
been sent into the anomalous Zone to
collect data on what exactly they were
dealing with but each time it seemed as
though the researchers were doomed to
know less and less about what they were
investigating from a distance the area
didn't even appear to be anomalous it
looks simply like a continuation of the
forest complete with the expected flora
fauna and even some distant evidence of
human habitation like an abandoned
building but without fail nobody who had
ever seen the building up close had ever
returned thanks to SCP 3930 they had
simply ceased to be because simply put
when you introduce something into
nothing the nothing wins Dr vasilev had
seen too many good men disappear into
Oblivion and soon it would be his turn
too but first something horrible would
crawl out of the Zone something that
shouldn't exist something that didn't
exist something that will never exist
and yet here it was in science the
observer effect is a dreaded phenomenon
all experiment involve the observation
of phenomenon to collect data and then
prove or disprove a hypothesis but the
observer effect describes the
frustrating scenario where the mere Act
of observing a phenomenon Alters it
reducing the usefulness of the data a
common example of this in mundane life
is checking the pressure of your car or
bike's tires to do this you need to let
out some air thus changing the pressure
but pressure holds a very different
meaning when you're working with what
might be the universe's largest patch of
nothing nothing because of their prime
directive namely researching the anomaly
Dr vasilev and his fellow scientists
were effectively forced to observe SCP
3930 and 3930 apparently doesn't like
that the scientists only notice sounds
at first barely perceptible little
screeches that could easily be written
off as your mind playing a trick on you
and in a sense it is but around SCP 3930
the tricks played by the Mind become a
lot more practical than anywhere else
what started as sounds soon came to take
on a visual form as more people became
aware of the anomaly and made futile
attempts to observe it from the outside
these scattered Visual and audio forms
soon became nicknamed screamers for
their horrific hateful wailing Dr
vasilia venese believed that despite the
extremely hostile nature of the
anomalies they had no way of ever
leaving the anomalous Zone that belief
was soon proved wrong and not long after
only 10 researchers remained it seemed
that the last of Dr Vasilio's hope hope
died with the Lost men but there was
some good news at least with only 10
left to observe the SCP 3930 anomaly the
screamers began to disappear and the
anomalous Zone became stable once more
10 it seemed was the upper limit of
observers that could distantly engage
with SCP 3930 before all hell broke
loose
and then the SCP Foundation arrived by
the time they reached the long since
defunct research Outpost Dr vasilov was
the only one left the final members of
his team had sacrificed themselves by
walking into the void and joining
non-existence vasil of himself remained
for only one purpose to tell the
foundation what he knew what they needed
to know before bowing out into SCP 3930
himself along with however many of the
foundation Personnel needed to go to
keep the number of active observers at a
nice clean 10 that is the burden of
knowing and accepting that burden is to
accept that you may one day need to
become unknown in order to protect your
fellow human beings from the horrors
that lay within but what is SCP 3930 and
what are these so-called screamers that
lurk within we have the answers to these
questions the only question for you is
whether you're ready to to take on the
grave responsibility of knowing too SCP
3930 does not exist that isn't just a
cover up by the 05 Council it doesn't
not exist in the official capacity it is
quite literally the world's largest
patch of nothingness and anything that
enters it is doomed to become nothing as
well it is a difficult concept to grasp
because fundamentally all language was
built as a tool to communicate Concepts
that on some level exist and SCP 3930
does not qualify Close Your Eyes For a
Moment seriously do it and try to
imagine nothing what do you see an
infinite space of pure Darkness a white
void stretching on into Infinity we're
sorry to inform you that neither of
these counts as being truly nothing
though Darkness may be the absence of
light to see that Blackness is to still
see something the darkness even implies
the existence of light the same can be
said for the white void for such a thing
to exist we need both the concepts of
the color white and the idea of a void
these are perhaps the lowest bars for
existence imaginable but SCP 3930
doesn't meet them it is well and truly
nothing nothing at all and because it is
nothing its containment procedures are
largely just a matter of information
control if nobody knows about it the
threat is contained if ever someone just
happened to want wander in they would
stop existing so the problem would take
care of itself as callus as that sounds
on its own the anomaly would technically
be harmless but when mixed with humans
Things become a whole lot more
complicated you see unless you have The
Misfortune to run into SCP 3930 you will
spend your life without ever having to
encounter true nothingness even when you
die the matter that comprises your body
and the energy that comprises your
Consciousness will remain they will just
be transferred into other forms humans
have no reason to ever encounter
nothingness and thus we have no
physiological or psychological equipment
to truly observe and comprehend
nothingness when we're given a true
blank our instinct is to fill it and
that right there is the true danger of
SCP 3930 and the very reason we have to
deal with screamers or as you may know
them pattern screamers that's right if
this whole setup seemed awfully familiar
to you it's because SCP 3930 is the
absolute Global epicenter of pattern
screamers the hateful entities we've
encountered before in anomalies like SCP
0000 nothingness is the natural
environment of pattern screamers but
because SCP 3930 is the only place where
true nothingness exists on our layer of
reality it's also the only place where
pattern screamers are able to directly
interact with humans if they become
powerful and defined enough often to
deadly and terrifying results pattern
screamers are an incredibly difficult
concept to wrap your head around
sometimes but allow us to explain close
your eyes again and this time picture a
clown not a specific clown like Ronald
McDonald or Pennywise you have to make
up your own clown let's say he's got
green hair a big blue rubber nose a wide
smile and polka dot clown shoes the
other details are up to you you go as
simple or as complicated as you like as
long as it's an entirely new clown
you've never seen in real life now hold
the image in your head really focus on
it you can even use your imagination to
make him dance or walk around
fundamentally this clown does not exist
aside from being the product of chemical
and electrical processes in your brain
if this is indeed an entirely new clown
in your mind it exists only on the level
of thought now now imagine if this clown
in your mind was somehow aware of the
fact it wasn't real and that it was only
the product of your imagination imagine
that this clown is infuriated by that
fact it despises you for bringing it
into being doomed to be a concept
straddling existence and non-existence
imagine this clown wants to hurt you it
really really really really wants to
hurt you with every fiber of its
non-existent being that right there is
is a pattern screamer and the
frightening thing about SCP 3930 is that
if enough people observe it directly
these pattern screamers can become real
they can crawl out of nothing and then
they can show you exactly how they feel
about you bringing them into existence
and when they're done you'll probably
regret ever existing in the first place
think of them as hostile sentient
hallucinations capable of reaching
maximum power around SCP 3930 this is
because when humans are given a lack of
stimulus their minds simply create their
own this is why people believe they see
the forest simply continuing into the
anomalous Zone it's the only way the
mind can comprehend what's going on here
it's like the phenomenon of perdolia
humans have a natural tendency to see
patterns in things even if they were
never really there it's from these very
patterns that the pattern screamers gain
both their form and their name their
monsters that we create curs to live
hellish half existences and they hate us
for it Dr vasil have described SCP 3930
as a kind of hateful mirror that
reflects back the ugliest shards of our
own minds first broken in the futile
quest to comprehend the true nature of
nothingness thousands have likely been
lost inside SCP 3930 if we can even call
them lost as lost implies that something
is still out there somewhere even if we
never actually find it this cannot be
said for the victims of SCP
3930 they are nowhere and nothing they
can't be found again because there is
nothing to find the foundation has used
d-class Personnel to perform Mann Recon
missions into SCP 3930 feeding
information back to the few members of
Mission Control permitted to be aware of
SCP 3930 is existence without immediate
termination the DCL classes have
ventured well into the heart of
nothingness even reaching and entering
the building that can be seen in the
distance there they found messes of
Haunting
inconsistencies the place looks like
it's been abandoned for decades but also
has evidence of recent habitation doors
and windows move curtains and hallways
go on forever they feel a sound in their
ears that's similar to the Screech of TV
static no not a screech really more of a
scream it's always in that moment that
the realization hits them they don't
exist not anymore and they haven't for a
little while now they're just a few
scattered memories of the foundation
researcher talking to them reflected
back by SCP 3930 is hateful mirror and
moments later they're gone almost like
they were never here at all so if ever
anyone asks you what is SCP 3930 you
know there's only ever one answer SCP
3930 does not exist in the a long
history of the world the planet has
played host to a wide variety of ancient
civilizations there are far far too many
of those for any one video to cover
people make it their careers to discover
and catalog the civilizations that
preceded Us in the modern era
archaeologists and historians make it
their life's work to learn everything
there is to know about these Mighty
Empires and kingdoms that span vast
swaths of land where there are now
dozens of countries a lot of these
civilizations are famous even School
children know about them take a look at
the Roman Empire for example everyone
knows about the mighty Roman Empire
Julius Caesar took control of the Roman
Republic and created the Empire that
would go on to be one of the largest
empires in history at the time it
controlled practically everything in
Europe and North Africa and even parts
of Asia the Romans made amazing
advancements in culture architecture law
and practically everything else in fact
their legacy can even be seen in pop
culture today the American Senate is
modeled off the Roman senate and
practically every nation in the world
has their own kind of wine a Roman
invention or take the Macedonian Empire
a lot of people don't know its name but
you almost definitely know the person
who created it Alexander the Great at
only 20 he took his father's Throne then
he began launching military Expeditions
and it soon became clear that young
Alexander was a brilliant tactician
never defeated in battle he managed to
extend his vast Empire across all of
West Asia and North Africa stretching
all the way to Egypt and India like
Caesar would go on to do after him he
managed to create one of the largest
empires in history except he did it all
before he even turned 30 though he died
young and his Empire was split apart by
his generals he brought Greek thought
culture and philosophy not to mention
science to the far reaches of inner Asia
and of course there is the Mongol Empire
led by The Fearsome gang gas Khan the
Mongols a nomadic people from Central
Asia were divided into dozens of
distinct tribes until genas Khan United
them under one flag and from there they
spread outward violently into the rest
of Asia conquering China Korea Eastern
Europe and practically all of Asia in
doing so they created the largest Empire
in history and killed somewhere near 40
million people in their conquests 10% of
the world's population at the time but
they also created a safe trade route
from China to Europe what is now known
as the Silk Road and their Innovations
with Cavalry would go on to inform
warfare using horses for the next 800
years moving out of Asia there are also
the legendary Mayans the Mayans were
more of a loose Confederation of
different tribes working together to
advance a common civilization they
didn't conquer as much land as the
others only one area in Central America
but they crafted a complex society with
laws Civic duties social rules and
extremely Advanced religious rights and
architecture if you go to South America
today you can still see the remnants of
their empire step pyramids that look
sort of like ziggurats deep in the South
American jungle interior they invented
astronomy calendars writing and many
forms of art like mosaics all without
contact with European Society needless
to say the advancements empires have
made throughout history are so important
we use them in our daily lives all the
time and we know a lot about these
ancient empire Ires too how could we not
they've made massive impacts on the
planet and population not to mention
religion culture Law Society as a whole
but what if there was an Empire on the
planet that was larger and more advanced
than all of the ones we just look
through and not just more advanced by a
little bit so Advanced that they were
creating nuclear reactors well before
Alexander was taking his first steps or
plutar was trying to complete a history
of the Greeks so Advanced that we still
don't totally understand what they were
capable of I'd certainly call that
anomalous wouldn't you and that's not
all what if this Empire also managed to
stay hidden from modern science for
centuries they didn't stay alive but
their ruins have never been found by the
scientific Community their relics have
been squirel away from the eyes of the
world over the decades you'd never find
a reference to the mechonit Empire in a
history textbook or in a museum and
that's for a very good reason the SCP
Foundation has spent an extremely large
amount of time and money ensuring that
the evidence of this ancient empire
never comes out to the rest of the world
but even if a culture creates anomalies
is the culture itself anomalous does it
need to be contained especially if
they're all long dead and their
technology has degraded into unusability
well maybe except their technology is
doing just fine 2,000 years en counting
their technology is still working
perfectly in some cases better than our
modern device es how can that be
possible how can that not be anomalous
well as unbelievable as it might seem
it's true we'll dive more into what
exactly this Empire out of Greece was in
a bit but for now we're going to look at
an SCP file associated with them except
this one couldn't be picked up stuffed
in a box and shipped off to a
containment Locker in site 19 you'll see
why in a minute but for now let's just
take a look at the file SCP 2406 lacks
any images or flashy documentation so no
clues there unless it's not possible to
photograph the anomaly for some reason H
the object class is safe and the
containment procedures aren't very long
a site provisional site 31 has been
constructed around SCP 246 and is under
the cover of a kazakhstani military base
provisional sites are temporary sites
that the foundation puts up in the field
to contain an anomaly that can easily be
transported somewhere else for
containment and if it's it's a
kazakhstani military facility the
anomaly is probably somewhere in
Kazakhstan and can't be moved H seems
reasonable enough all Personnel who work
directly with SCP 246 are required to
wear a type a hazmat suit when in
contact with the anomaly and to undergo
a full decontamination bath upon exiting
whatever SCP 2406 is being in direct
contact with it can be dangerous to
humans so the foundation uses
specialized hazardous material suits the
big yellow jumpsuits you see near
radiation or chemical spill sites on top
of that an armed contingent of guards
are to remain in place in and around
provisional site 31 to ensure no one
unauthorized accesses the anomaly though
you'd have to wonder why anyone would
try to access a military base the
containment procedures close out by
declaring that anyone wanting to
directly interact with SCP
2461 whatever it is needs to get
authorization from their site director
so SCP p2406 has at least one sub
anomaly to deal with obviously the
foundation is very interested in keeping
this anomaly or these anomalies secret
and protected at all costs as well as
limiting human exposure to something
potentially dangerous now let's take a
look at the description SCP 2406 is a
mechanical automaton that's 93 m tall
and weighs approximately 210 metric tons
for the Americans Among Us that's about
300 ft in height and 230 tons over
450,000 lb no wonder the foundation
couldn't move it after investigating
research concluded that SCP 2406 wasn't
sentient so it wasn't a robot or cyborg
or artificial intelligence an automaton
is a machine to perform a specific task
and this thing whatever it is was
controlled by at least six different
operators if not more they piloted the
machine using 160 different Valves and
levers with than torso head and chest of
the automaton and if it has a head and
chest it has limbs limbs that were
controlled by a combination of
pneumatics hydraulics and Clockwork
Machinery but controlling is one thing
how the heck does something like this
get the power to move the answer is a
nuclear reactor embedded in its torso
with power cables running to its arms
and legs yep unbelievable as it may seem
this ancient curiosity was powered by
the same Source our modern aircraft
carriers and nuclear submarines use SCP
2406 was discovered on August 7th 1985
in the arcom desert but not by the
foundation the arlum desert used to be
part of the ARL sea before the Soviets
drained part of it it was during one of
these drainings that the Russian
military discovered SCP
2406 by tracking the radiation coming
from it as soon as they realized what
they found wasn't some sort of abandoned
Warhead or uranium Deposit they called
in the G ru's P division the unit of the
Soviet government who dealt with
anomalies in the same way the foundation
did they kept custody of the anomaly but
only for a few years when the USSR
collapsed in 1991 the foundation stepped
in with their agents and took control of
the anomaly while everyone else in the
area was busy dealing with the political
Fallout they immediately began
performing research and learned that the
material SCP 2406 is made of isn't just
one metal but a toughened alloy of
copper zinc nickel lead and iron the
mixture is why the metal looks bronze
despite not having any Bronze in it they
also found two markings on it one was on
the outside of its back and showed the
agan numeral for nine does that mean
there are at least eight more of these
things buried somewhere maybe but the
foundation hasn't found any of them
what's more interesting is that the
numeral is agian Greek despite SCP 2406
lying in a lake in the rlca pretty far
from Greece the front of the anomaly its
chest has an intricate symbol of a
hammer striking an anvil on it the right
arm of the anomaly has a nozzle with
piping attached to it the piping leads
to a pressurized chamber within SCP
246 that is empty but the foundation did
managed to find Trace residue of various
chemicals such as Pine resin NEPA quick
lime calcium phosphide and sulfur inside
the corners of the tank not
coincidentally those are the exact same
chemicals used to create Greek fire A
Primitive chemical weapon similar to
Napal that the ancient Greeks used in
Warfare between this and the agian
numeral the foundation judged that SCP
246 was almost definitely constructed in
Greece and brought here for some reason
the left arm of the anomaly isn't
attached to it in fact initial reports
said it was torn off at the shoulder and
couldn't be found with the rest of it
but it seems that the foundation managed
to recover its sense detailed in one of
the addenda in the file chemicals
weren't the only thing they found in
inside SCP 246 when they busted the main
access plate open researchers found
something decidedly more morbid six
different human skeletons located inside
its torso area were removed and
cataloged before being carbon dated to
1100 BC over 3,000 years old and they
were all wearing an extremely strange
set of armor while it looked Greek it
was made of a strange lead copper alloy
and filled with aestus lining presumably
the armor was designed to absorb the
radiation put out by SCP 246s reactor
there were also tubes from the helmets
leading to the outside so they could
breathe safe air one of the levers
pumped water into the tubes so that the
pilots didn't die of thirst and another
tube was near the groin probably so they
could pee seems like the designers
ensuring that whoever was piloting SCP
2406 could do so for hours or days the
foundation ensured through testing that
SCP 2406 doesn't work the limbs don't
move and many of the levers have rusted
or broken all of that damage from disuse
is repairable but there is even more
extensive damage from combat the limbs
and head were first discovered run
through by long sharp spikes made of an
unknown substance though it feels like
kiten its molecular structure is closer
to Coral and on top of that it's
biological and contains some elements of
human DNA parts of its limbs are also
crushed or indented with a segmented
pattern like a boa constrictor wrapping
around its prey the the evidence
suggests that SCP 246 was in an intense
fight with some sort of giant monster
and lost but that's all in the past SCP
246 also has a more present problem its
reactor it melted through the back of
the anomaly penetrating the Earth and
seems to still be burning incredibly hot
and radioactive nearly a kilometer under
the surface Engineers think that when it
was intact it works similarly to Natural
nuclear reactions rather than modern
reactors like when a uranium deposit
begins to undergo fion if nothing else
it means that SCP 246s designers were
studying those and were far more
advanced scientifically than any other
culture on the face of the planet at the
time that we know of while they were
investigating the wreck Foundation
Personnel also discovered something
interesting a watertight ceramic jar
like the ones ancient Egyptians used to
preserve organs when they broke the seal
they found two tightly bound Scrolls
written in a unique language resembling
meinian Greek it took 10 years of
research for the foundation's best
linguists to translate the Scrolls what
they found confirmed their Theory the
Scrolls were religious and written by a
group called the followers of meccan the
ancient precursors to what we now call
the infamous Church of the broken God an
anomalous cult that seeks to rebuild
their deity and make themselves more
than human the foundations had run-ins
with them in the past but the documents
indicate that 3,000 years ago they
weren't just a cult they were an Empire
the first scroll was translated to the
following the colosi were constructed in
her schema the colosi were constructed
to defend secure contain the enemy Grand
cist ion betrayer of man destroyer of
progress sorcerer king of aditum a
desolate domain of failed and Fallen
creation built with the bodies flesh of
dead Gods upon a throne of black
ambition the enemy plots the enemy is
not a priest they are a merchant and
they have sold the whole world totality
the colossi were constructed in her
schema the colossi were constructed to
defend secure contain the profane tools
must be broken uncreated drink deep the
silver blood of meain May her sacrifice
not be in vain strange but definitely
religious it seems to be a dedication to
the broken God meain the colossi were
created to fight their ancient enemy the
sarcs but the second document is much
more interesting this is a testament of
matriarch uaia legates faithful servant
of McCain I am not a warrior but all
Warriors are dead breaking themselves
upon the enemy's host the enemy has set
their plan into motion the sorcerer King
surrounds himself with corpses to fight
is to grow his Legions Egypt Retreats
from the world the hites have fallen
into chaos the conspirators of creit
have sacrificed their own the Asian have
fallen into barbarism the city of a
thousand pillars is forever lost has
always been lost even the DEA grow
desperate With the Enemy at their border
the center collapses kingdoms crumble
the damage is done the light of Reason
flickers and wains but meccan sacrificed
herself so that we might be free we
refuse to return to that Darkness we
would rather die but the Siege at Euros
was one we must strike while the metal
is hot and thus we March for cythera at
the end of all things we have crossed
the wi dark sea we have seen Villages
ravaged by the Red Death we have seen
the Dead the dying and the deathless we
cast the accursed to Holy flame we enter
his desolate domain and in our left hand
we carry our answer we cannot undo what
has been done but we can delay the saric
dawn so it seems that the ancient mechan
empire were once at war with another
Empire the hated sarst losing and all
their allies dying they poured their
resources into these massive mechs and
sent them deep into enemy territory
equipped with some sort of Doomsday
weapon as a hope for Success what
happens next is unfortunately a mystery
on December 12th of 1998 the foundation
found something almost 30 km away from
SCP 2406 during a routine Patrol at
first the researchers were confused had
they found another wreck one of the
other eight mentioned or perhaps the
body of the mysterious creature as
cp2406 had fallen in battle with but
after Excavating it they realized they
had found something they hadn't even
been looking for to begin with scp2 246s
left arm the way it landed suggested
that it had been torn off during the
battle and hurled away but what monster
could possibly throw something that
heavy 30 entire kilom either way what
the foundation found attached to SCP
2406 is arm is much more interesting the
researchers aren't sure what it is but
it's much different from the rest of SCP
2406 it seems to be some kind of weapon
but one that's not made of any metals on
Earth and with an incredibly anomalous
design the foundation Personnel not sure
of what to make of it designated at SCP
24061 its purpose is similarly unknown
and the consensus seems to be that
whatever it is it far exceeds human
understanding but what the foundation is
sure of is that it seems to bend reality
near it though they're not sure how
because it doesn't seem to affect
anything the foundation's best minds are
stumped by it all they can say for
certain is that if it was ever repaired
powered up and activated it could do
unprecedented damage to local reality so
interaction with it was highly regulated
and the foundation put it away with the
rest of SCP
2406 history is often the greatest
teacher by looking at the past we can
learn from it with the benefit of
hindsight such as in the early 20th
century when the entire planet was in
the grip of a horrifying War at the time
this conflict was often referred to as
the Great War although there was little
great about it others knew it as the war
to end all wars the largest armed
engagement the world had known although
it would not be the last today with that
hindsight we just mentioned we know it
as World War I in June 1914 an arch Duke
of Austria was shot dead by a Serbian
assassin and as a result of the
complicated treaties forged between
various Nations soon much of the world
was involved in a war that started out
as little more than a scuffle between
neighbors the horrors of trench warfare
the Carnage caused by the earliest
chemical weapons and armored tanks left
a permanent and Lasting scar on the
world's history one still mourned and
remembered to this day the advances in
chemical and mechanized Warfare that
took place during World War I rang from
the use of chemicals like tear gas used
to disable targets to more lethal
compounds like mustard gas and of course
this was the first war to introduce
tanks to the battlefield although these
were clumsy and cumbersome to begin with
it was arguably the Advent of the first
world war that forced many advancements
in armored Warfare it was the belief of
many individuals on all sides that if
the Great War was made too gruesome and
horrific to continue it would come to
its natural end this of course did not
happen only encouraging each participant
of World War I to continue advancing
their Weaponry but what if there were
weapons developed during World War I
that were too dangerous to be deployed
with every side looking for advantage
over their adversaries what if some
turned to the unethical even the
anomalous to gain the upper hand in the
war introducing SCP
186 otherwise known as to end all wars
try to imagine Weaponry that was so
incredibly Advanced for the mid 1910s
yet so horribly and unjustifiably cruel
worse than gas that can cause blisters
to form not only on the skin but also
inside the lungs more advanced than
armored vehicles with mounted machine
guns crawling across no man's land it's
hard to picture something that could be
more devastating than that especially
for the time period but a good measure
of a weapon's destructive power is
usually found in the damage it leaves in
its wake in this case SCP 186 is exactly
that not the anomalous weapons
themselves but the sight of a battle
that took place between the 24th of July
and the 13th of August in
1917 the event became known as the
Battle of hottin woods but you won't
find any mention of it in the history
books any and all records of the battle
have been secretly expunged by the SCP
Foundation and their own archive is now
the only place where someone can find
the details of what happened over those
few weeks the engagement took place
between the German Imperial Army and
forces belonging to Russia's provisional
government a small Skirmish in
comparison to the enormity of many
battles of the first world war so what
happened at the Battle of hottin woods
to make it so horrible that it had to be
stricken from the historical record for
that we have to go back to htin a small
settlement in Western Ukraine in July of
1917 the surviving remnants of a Russian
division had been scattered the Germans
counterattacked against the kinsky
offensive had driven the Russian troops
to the dense forest that surrounded the
town of etin you might be forgiven for
thinking that the outnumbered Russian
Force was decimated by almost 500 German
soldiers pursuing them but you would be
very very wrong as the opposing forces
met they engaged each other in a
fearsome battle but this was unlike any
encounter that had taken place over the
course of World War I or ever would
again both sides were armed with
anomalous Weaponry possessing technology
Beyond any any that had ever been seen
at the time to this day the SCP
Foundation has been baffled by these
weapons even with their unique
understanding of the anomalous
Foundation researchers had been unable
to replicate any of them and instead
keeps them secured in the Munitions wing
of site 23 all under the designation of
SCP
186-16 D1 is a highly modified scoda m19
9 machine gun however rather than
behaving like a standard firearm this
gun would cause rapid forming growths
not unlike tumors to appear within the
body of its targets another was
concertina wire a form of spiraled razor
wire commonly used in trenches only this
wire was coated in an unknown compound
that caused permanent hallucination
whenever the wire cut a person and
allowed the hallucinogen to enter their
bloodstream a number of rifle cartridges
were also found littered around SCP 186
sounds pretty normal for a first World
War battlefield right except these
cartridges were not filled with
gunpowder like you would expect them to
be instead they inexplicably contained
human bone ground into powder the
purpose of this ammunition or how it was
manufactured is still unknown to the SCP
Foundation as if a gun that causes
tumors and hallucination triggering wire
weren't bad enough Foundation
researchers also found a number of
grenades used used by the troops at the
site of SCP 186 these were British
Empire standard issue number 27 grenades
but they contained a unique anomalous
gas that was capable of passing through
any and all filters gas masks were
developed during World War One to
protect soldiers from mustard and tear
gas on the battlefield but these masks
only offered basic filtration by today's
standards even so the gas contained in
these grenades was strong enough to
negate any and all fil filtration
systems but that was far from its worst
quality did this unknown gas choke
troops not quite did it disable them
like tear gas in a way yes but this gas
did so by making any Soldier exposed to
it experiened the sensation of having
their bodies set on fire constantly also
recovered at SCP 186 where the remains
of some form of explosive and it is
believed by the foundation that it was
detonated at the culmination of the
Battle of Houston Woods causing
approximately a third of the battle's
total casualties Foundation researchers
estimate that almost 300 civilians were
either caught in the blast or died as a
result of the crossfire between the
German and Russian forces the soldiers
involved were also all permanently
incapacitated or killed or at least
almost all of them so where did these
anomalous weapons come from and why were
they used just in this battle not
throughout the first world war according
to records kept from the public by the
SCP Foundation the German troops in the
Houston Woods were accompanied by a
Hungarian adviser to their military
named Mattias nemes under his orders
they specifically targeted and tracked
the Russian division that was retreating
from them who were similarly
accompanying a French scientist Dr Jean
tand it was these two men nemes and Dand
who were responsible for arming the
Germans and Russians with their arsenals
of anomalous weapons they had ensured
that their inventions of death had only
received limited manufacturing and had
intentionally joined opposing sides of
the war effort to test their Creations
in real Combat in other words it appears
that Dand and NES has been working
together since the beginning of the war
and the troops they were with had been
manipulated into taking part in a big
test these soldiers were just as unlucky
as the civilians caught in the crossfire
today today the SCP Foundation has
established an automated security
perimeter around the site of SCP 186
preventing access to anyone unless
authorized everything within the
perimeter is frequently patrolled and
observed by security Personnel why the
need for so much security at an Old
Battleground given the damage caused by
the use of so many anomalous weapons
including those that the foundation was
unable to recover the area of SCP 186
has become a hot spot for unusual
happening
even long after the battle of huon woods
ended these anomalies include abnormal
environmental or weather conditions for
example all the trees in the
southwestern portion of the former
Battlefield died and decomposed at an
accelerated rate in 1923 while the
temperature dropped to a permanent -5° C
4 years later but yet there was never
any snowfall then there were the sounds
of gunfire in 1932 despite there being
nobody inside the scp1 186 site a number
of years later a pair of foundation
agents disappeared on a routine patrol
of the area and were never seen again of
course 23 years after the end of the war
to end all wars the world was plunged
into chaos and found itself at War once
again during this time SCP Foundation
Personnel were instructed to evacuate
the site of SCP 186 based on
intelligence from their Allied
operatives who were working undercover
inside the thir Reich as the foundation
disembarked their observation posts a
faint glow was visible coming from SCP
186 4 years passed and the second world
war came to a close the foundation
returned to reestablish their
containment of s SCP 186 and immediately
discovered 13 corpses dressed in German
army uniforms bearing the Insignia of
the fourth Panzer Army there were
further 27 bodies of soldiers wearing
the Garb of the Soviet 22nd Army both
sets of bodies had already begun
decaying although someone had removed
the dog tags and anything else that
could identify these dead troops it
seems that history had to some extent
repeated itself as the Nazi and Soviet
forces had clashed on the same
Battlefield where their German and
Russian predecessors had fought during
the Battle of Houston Woods years later
in 1959 a large sinkhole formed in the
Northeast portion of SCP 186 four men
were found wandering nearby all
extremely disoriented wearing
decomposing military uniforms were they
lost survivors of the Nazi Soviet battle
no these men were in World War I
uniforms German Empire and Russian
standard issue they had survived the
battle of Houston woods and Were Somehow
Still Standing even though they should
have died during the first world war how
did these troops manage this well the
the final anomalous weapon recovered at
the side of SCP 186 were mortar shells
but unsurprisingly these weren't your
standard high explosive artillery much
like those grenades mentioned earlier
these mortar shells contained a unique
previously unseen gas but instead of
causing the Perpetual pain of being on
fire this gas altered the biology of
animal cells that it came into contact
with somehow it triggered a change that
prevented a body's cells from ceasing
life function keeping them continuously
operational in other words it meant that
any soldiers exposed to this gas simply
could not die that's right some of the
troops involved in the Battle of Houston
Woods are still alive to this day the
SCP Foundation immediately began
Excavating the sinkhole and discovered
23 bodies buried beneath in a mass grave
there were more of the surviving World
War I soldiers kept alive for decades by
the mortar gas some of them still had
infected wounds and Battlefield injuries
that should have killed them yet their
bodies refused to Die the soldiers were
rounded up and hul off to site 23 where
the foundation researchers began
assessing them however they were unable
to glean any useful information from the
German and Russian troops that had been
Unearthed all of the soldiers exhibited
symptoms of extensive psychological
trauma and had developed various mental
disorders while buried alive under the
battlefield they had all been driven to
sanity perhaps as a result of their
unnaturally extended lifespans maybe
from being buried underground and unable
to die for so long or perhaps it was the
wartime atrocities they witnessed that
drove the soldiers over the brink
history is a great teacher but those
willing to forget its mistakes are often
doomed to repeat them Matias nemes and
Dr Jean Duran created the anomalous
weapons responsible for SCP 186 and
similar mind would later go on to build
the atomic bomb and countless weapons of
mass destruction after World Wars The
Suffering of countless troops and
civilians these parts of history mean
nothing if we don't allow ourselves to
learn from them and maybe that's our
curse as a species that we are doomed to
fight the war to end all wars again and
again and again gregori gusakov and
Anatoli corov both age 10 tiptoed
through the dark Deep Woods bordering
their quaint Russian village of oeni the
year was 1990 a turbulent time for the
people of Russia seeing as the Soviet
Union was on the precipice of collapse
but for these two young boys Global
geopolitics was the last thing on their
minds they were too busy hunting for the
legendary monstrous witch known only as
babaa for those in our audience who grew
up in Eastern Europe or those at least
decently familiar with Slavic folklore
and or the John Wick film series mention
of the name Baba yaa likely sends a
slight chill down your spine and if it
doesn't just wait by the end of this
video you'll be afraid to go into the
woods alone not that going with others
would save you as poor little gregori
and Anatoli were about to find out the
hard way they forged on through those
witchy Woods by our standards the boys
were tough and headr strong after all
the Russian Wilderness could be a bral
place to grow up and in a town like oeni
the old ways of stoicism and
perseverance were prized over fear and
caution all except for one particular
area the supernatural like many small
villages all over the world at every
point in history oeni had its fair share
of local superstitions Chief among them
was the belief that the local forest was
enchanted and that when people wandered
in among the trees many of them would
never return they would fall into the
Gnar clutches of the carnivorous witch
babaa and their bones would lay among
the roots and Dead Leaves until they
someday crumbled into dust it was
starting to get dark out when the two
boys had first set off it had been with
the intention of proving their metal
among the other local children they
didn't fear babaa the old witch in the
woods was just another fairy story meant
to frighten children and they weren't
children anymore though they would never
live to be men it wasn't long before
they were beyond the point of no return
which way was out and which way was
further in it hardly mattered anymore as
K on birds Cod far above the bravado
that put them here was starting to
falter now but neither dared show it
they'd rather be put in Mortal Peril
than show fear in front of one another
was something moving in the distant
Shadows a thin Twisted human figure
impossible to make out save for the
faint glow of its eyes in the Gathering
dark they couldn't tell what was real
and what was their mind playing cruel
tricks on them a horse whisper issued
through the brittle trees in the moments
that followed it was an ancient voice a
voice that had echoed in the nightmares
of generations a voice that had seen
centuries it spoke in an older Russian
dialect that neither of the young boys
could understand but somehow the essence
of its message still rung clear in their
hearts and Minds welcome
little
children to my
Forest here your lives are forfeit you
are my
property I look forward to chewing the
tender meat of your young
bones that was all they needed to hear
to start running gregori and Anatoli
turn and fled screaming for help into
the darkness of the forest both gasped
as they ran through what seemed to be a
giant spider web they spack and
spluttered trying to swat away the silky
strands as they ran from The Voice
little did they know what they just run
through was no spiderweb they tried to
press on but their footsteps slowed the
forest was changing around them twisting
shifting sparkling what had seemed
terrifying before was suddenly oddly
beautiful the two two boys just stood
and watched as the forest turned into a
gorgeous Technicolor light show unlike
anything they'd ever seen before strange
figures hopped and danced through the
foliage one tall figure approached them
out of the trees a beautiful Fair haired
Maiden the two boys were entranced by
her their hearts filled with pure Golden
Light why were they running before they
couldn't even remember they just smiled
as the woman approached them in her long
flowing dress smiling back she was like
something out of a fairy tale they
didn't react they didn't even realize
what was happening as the jaws of the
horrible ancient old Crone closed around
their skulls for the last time rori and
Anatoli were never seen again just
another two children gone missing in the
woods the latest entries on a long list
of tragedies to hit the village of oreni
but they were also the straws that broke
the camel's back the villagers were sick
of living in fear under the fabled witch
they would have their Revenge the men of
the village gathered up their weapons
and formed a Hunting Party guns torches
knives axes and fury they would slay the
Beast that had taken so many of their
friends and their children in the woods
as soon as their forces were assembled
they charged into the forest looking for
blood with their numerical advantage and
single-minded determination it didn't
take them long to find the monster in
the woods she was every bit as hideous
and nightmarish as they had anticipated
a gnarled snarling Crone with long
clawed fingers and dirty fangs they got
her in their sights and prepared to open
fire but none of them were ready for
Baba yaga's counter offensive she moved
like a leaf in a strong wind Swift and
effortless the men who'd made the
mistake of getting too close to her with
knives and axes tasted her terrible
wrath she tore through them with claws
like iron sank her fangs into their
flesh lifted and tossed them like ragd
dolls how could she be so fast and so
strong the men were terrified this was
no mere woman it was a true monster
squeezed into a barely human form by the
time the creature was finally
incapacitated he' taken countless
bullets and Strikes how any creature
could survive such an assault was
unimaginable several members of The
Hunting Party were dead by this Point
others had been overtaken by a strange
form of Madness a couple of them had
been given to constant giggling fits or
were speaking long strings of nonsense
others had been rendered entirely
catatonic by the experience it was clear
that the witch had powers beyond their
understanding they needed to return it
to the village and destroy it as quickly
as possible the monster was bound and
dragged back to oeni after seeing how it
Bewitched some of the men they avoided
direct contact whenever possible they
would do everything they could to see
Justice Done of course there would be no
due process for babaa the violence that
had erupted in the forest was more than
enough proof to justify the beast's
immediate death sentence the local
priest gave a prayer though he remarked
that he was sure this monster was the
creation and servant of the devil and
the execution commenced a local used a
blessed sword Anointed with holy water
to hack off the Baba yaga's head its
body was shot several times for good
measure and it was finally dowsed in
gasoline and set on fire the remains
were buried just outside the village
limits hoping that the Baba yagas evil
wouldn't continue to haunt their Town
even in death isolated villages in the
Russian step aren't famous for their
communication with Outsiders especially
back in 1990 when the Soviet Union was
still Clinging On to control and the
internet was still in its infancy it
took a few weeks for news of a village
capturing a so-called local which to
reach the SCP Foundation after closely
studying The Peculiar disappearance
records in the area they sent over a
Detachment of field agents to
investigate and perhaps conduct a few
interviews with the locals they had no
way of knowing there wouldn't be any
left by the time they arrived when the
field agents reached oeni it was already
a ghost town not a single Survivor was
found only the evidence of fresh Carnage
desiccated bodies were found in some of
the Village's houses in other 's only
body parts a hole in the ground next to
the Village seemed to show evidence of
some Subterranean creature clawing its
way back up to the top whatever this
creature was he clearly crawled back up
from the earth and exacted bloody
revenge against those who had buried it
blood trails from some of the bodies
leading back into the woods made it
clear where the creature had fled to
after massacring the entire Village
given the sudden increase in the
Situation's severity mobile task force
Epsilon 6 AKA The Village idiots were
brought in to apprehend The Fugitive
witch but much like the literal Village
idiots that had come before them this
MTF had no idea what they were up
against they entered the forest outside
oeni with Superior Tactics and weaponry
to the villagers with orders to contain
the creature at all costs they didn't
exactly know what they were searching
for in the dark amongst the trees but
when the first operatives laid eyes on
the Twisted Old Crone they almost
reflexively relaxed their guard for some
of the village idiots this would be the
last mistake they ever made some of the
operatives began to feel funny much like
gregori Anatoli and some members of The
Hunting Party they began to see the
forest warping and shifting around them
they giggled at all the funny colors
inside feeling an overwhelming sense of
calmness and Euphoria it was honestly
the best they had felt in years perhaps
they were wrong about hunting the witch
in here maybe the real anomaly here was
a Russian Forest that made you feel
awesome when you stepped inside while
the affected agents were giggling away
in their own little La La Land babaa was
bringing the pain with the same freakish
speed strength and ferocity that had
surprised The Hunting Party weeks
earlier the witch was tearing through
MTF Epsilon 6 ripping through Harden
tactical armor with her long claws and
teeth she took shot after shot enough
tranquilizer to put down an elephant but
she kept fighting in the end the
training and numerical super superiority
of the task force one out they were able
to secure and contain the babaa soon
redesignated SCP 352 and take it to a
nearby Foundation containment site for
further studies there they officially
recorded all the details from the
creature's incredible speed and strength
to its regenerative abilties so
extensive that it could even survive
being decapitated and burned but what
about the hallucinogenic effects like a
hungry spider the Baba yaga's true power
comes in her ability to been a deadly
web her body is able to produce long
thin hairlike fibers each one coated in
powerful hallucinogenic enzymes that
induce a sense of placid euphoric
Stillness in its victims when it isn't
engaging multiple targets the creature
can sometimes take multiple days to
consume a single still living victim
taking them apart and eating them piece
by piece speaking of eating as you can
probably imagine in order to keep SCP
352 uneventfully contained it's ideal to
make make sure it isn't hangry in order
to keep 352 well fed they need to stock
up on its favorite food human flesh
though specifically 352 has a real
hankering for babies while the
foundation are currently exploring
anomalous means of keeping the babaa FED
until those means are fully ironed out
they need to keep this monster fed the
oldfashioned way only ever withdrawing
food as punishment if it attempts to
breach containment after all there's a
very good reason why parents and
children across the Slavic World fear
babaa she's always hungry and in the end
she always gets what she wants you're
driving down a long Highway lost in an
area you don't know too well trying to
find the right turn that'll have you
heading back towards your home you keep
driving the nighttime quiet all around
you deciding to try and break that
silence you reach for the radio turn
turning the dial to filter through all
the garbled distorted voices and songs
from nearby local radio stations that
are too far out of range to come through
clearly you try your best to listen to
the music from One radio station but
eventually the sound of the static only
makes you wish for the silence you were
trying to break your fingers nudge the
tuning dial on your car radio once again
and finally something comes through it
isn't loud or clear but under the
Distortion you can make out the sound
and it isn't a song or even a late news
broadcast the first thing you hear
sounds like a short musical tone only
for about 10 seconds next a young girl's
voice speaking in a language you don't
understand even through the distorted
audio from her accent you assume it's
Russian but you still have no idea what
the word she's saying mean with nothing
else to listen to you let the broadcast
play still driving alone in the dark
with nothing but the Str strange
adolescent voice to accompany you your
mind begins to wander she sounds like
she's speaking something but the rhythm
of the words is somehow familiar to you
even though you don't speak Russian then
it hits you she's counting but you don't
feel smart for having worked that out
instead something about knowing that
makes your blood run cold you carry on
driving through the night after a few
short minutes the rushan girl stops
counting and the musical tone plays
again under the Distortion leaving you
alone in the car once again with nothing
but your thoughts and questions of what
exactly you just heard thankfully we
have the answer what you heard was SCP
3034 since 1964 this same broadcast has
been made a vast number of times 627
times in fact you'd have to be within 2
km of the broadcast point of origin to
hear it where Foundation Personnel have
tried and failed numerous times to
triangulate its source the numbers heard
recited in the SCP 3034 broadcast are
actually a countdown from 200 read aloud
in Russian all Foundation staff are able
to do while stationed at the nearby
provisional site 3034 is scour radio
frequencies for occurrences of SCP 3034
checking their equipment is properly
maintained and calibrated before they
are eventually rotated off site and
replaced with a new group of staff there
is only one rule that any foundation
members working at provisional site 3034
must follow there are only permitted to
send one radio transmission with their
equipment a single phrase in reply to
the SCP 3034 broadcast VI Haru receiving
this the countdown stops and the
broadcast ends but never permanently SCP
3034 has been known to repeatedly occur
seemingly at random the shortest
recorded Gap between broadcasts was 2
weeks while the longest so far lasted
six whole months you may have heard the
term number station mentioned before but
these are far from just random numerical
sequences sent out over the airwaves
without purpose General speculation
surrounding number stations points to
them being the tools of Espionage agents
a way of sending coded highly sensitive
messages or information without the risk
of compromising their cover the use of
number station Transmissions is of often
attributed to spies working on foreign
soil who utilize shortwave radio
frequencies speech synthesis Morse code
and either regular or sporadic timing
schedules while it's true that times
have changed and technology has
progressed considerably there appears to
be evidence that number stations are
still used among various intelligence
and Espionage agencies today despite
being considered an old-fashioned method
of communication these lowtech shortwave
stations remain a viable reliable option
for the transmission and reception of
intelligence to field agents the conet
project is a comprehensive Archive of
this phenomenon and its founder Aken
Fernandez has long been fascinated by
number stations according to him this
system is completely secure because the
messages can't be tracked the recipient
could be anywhere you just send spies to
the country and get them to buy a radio
they know where to tune and when so what
does the distorted broadcast of numbers
for from SCP 3034 me is it the work of
covert agents and if so whose side are
they on most importantly why does the
SCP Foundation make certain there are
always three of its Personnel on site
ready to send the all aswell message
whenever SCP 3034 begins broadcasting
SCP 3034 was first discovered by the
foundation in
1964 after a Defector from the Soviet
grup a division tasked with acquiring
and studying anomalies on behalf of the
USSR gave them a tip Commander Robert
malfus along with a team of six
including a man named agent Browning
selected for his knowledge of Russian
dialects were sent to investigate at
provisional site 3034 here the team
uncovered partially burned records and
log books all kept in Russian along with
evidence that the site had been
evacuated shortly before their arrival
carved into a desk also in Russian were
two phrases don't let her finish and
tell her all is well on the team's
second day at the site an automated
alarm sounded at 7:30 a.m. alerting them
to the incoming SCP 3034 broadcast
following the instructions on the desk
agent Browning was able to stop the
broadcast telling the young Russian girl
that all was well a tape was partially
recovered by the team from the site and
translated from Russian the grup members
that had previously inhabited the
station had interrogated one of their
own a man named Sergey whom they accused
of stealing state property she's not
State Property he replied she has a name
while his grup Superior accused Sergey
of planning to defect to the United
States allegedly in exchange for money
and Asylum Sergey denied any collusion
with America he claimed that the grup at
provisional site 3034 were meddling with
powers they could not possibly hope to
understand his Superior a man named Vaso
dismissed this claiming their work to be
no different to the United States
experimentation with a Atomic weapons at
the time one does not make deals with
atom bombs Serge argued one certainly
does not sacrifice little girls to them
shortly after this a struggle broke out
with Sergey having to be restrained
while urging vaslav to cease any and all
interference with it the man spoke of
terrible nightmares that he'd had voices
screaming in the darkness that's what it
wants vlo that's what it is you cannot
make a deal with this thing we have
finally contained it and now you want to
offer it the tapes audio ends shortly
after this point with no clear answer as
to what Sergey was referring to or what
offer these Russian operatives had made
to it ever since the discovery of SCP
3034 members of the SCP Foundation have
worked tirelessly to understand the
purpose of these countdowns as well as
determine their origin by September 2012
Dr shill was reaching the end of his
tether with the investigation into the
SCP 3034 broadcast
over almost half a century the
foundation had made well over 600
recordings of the Russian girls
countdowns but still hadn't determined
any noteworthy information they were
prohibited from contacting the girl via
the same radio frequency only permitted
to use the phrase that stopped her
countdowns running out of options schul
kill contacted his colleague Dr Emerson
asking for an in-depth vocal analysis of
the various recordings of SCP
3034 even if they could narrow narrow
down where the broadcast was coming from
Maybe by determining the girl's
geographical location from her dialect
then that would be at least some slight
progress into understanding SCP 3034
while unable to discover the girl's
location Dr Emerson's analysis did yield
some interesting findings Emerson
learned that these countdowns were not
pre-recorded the variations in the
Russian girl's voice her tone her pitch
all seemed to indicate that every
instance of the broad
was unique rather than use the same
recording this girl had been counting
down over and over hundreds of times for
almost 50 years but there was more schul
kill and Emerson then examined the
Distortion The Sounds interfering with
the audio of the Russian girls
countdowns what had initially seemed
like garbled static seemed to actually
be additional voices and much like the
girl's voice these distorted voices were
unique different in every Broad
however schul kill and Emerson were
unable to accurately determine what
these voices were saying given that the
girls countdowns were always cut short
by the use of the phrase all as well the
doctors did not have long enough samples
of the audio to analyze the other
distorted voices with permission from
the foundation the next five occurrences
of the SCP 3034 broadcast were allowed
to carry on for longer giving the two
doctors enough audio to determine
exactly what the distorted voices were
and the results were extremely troubling
they were screams thousands upon
thousands of children's voices endlessly
screaming both Dr Emerson and Dr schill
agreed that it would be best to continue
responding to SCP 3034 with the correct
phrase and refused to analyze the
distorted screaming audio any further 3
years later while stationed at
provisional site 3034 a foundation
researcher named Dr Uriel Willis decided
to take matters into her own hands she
conducted an experiment that had not
been sanctioned by the foundation and
attempted to make contact with a Russian
girl giving the countdowns hearing Dr
Willis's voice the girl stopped her
countdown after five long painfully
silenced seconds a new broadcast was
heard a piercing high-pitch Screech that
caused extreme pain and dizziness to all
the staff working on site unable to Bear
the disorienting sound Dr Willis told
the girl all is well and caused the
noise to stop the following day SCP
researchers noted that there had been a
significant increase in cases of missing
children all around the world a majority
of these disappearances happened at the
same time the Screech had been broadcast
and remain unsolved to this day Dr
Willis faced disciplinary action from
the SCP Foundation and any further
testing of SCP 3034 and attempts to
communicate with the Russian girl were
prohibited only one dis change has been
noted in the SCP 3034 broadcast since
this incident almost a month later the
countdown was detected and the correct
phrase given but researchers noted that
instead of starting her countdown from
200 this time the Russian girl began
counting down from
199 nobody knows what will happen if the
Russian girls countdown is allowed to
reach zero Personnel working at
provisional site 3034 are told to always
offer her the necessary phrase before
this point in the count down attempting
to interfere with the broadcast by
contacting this girl directly not only
resulted in intense pain for scp's staff
but also seems to have caused an
unconfirmed number of child
disappearances around the globe as well
as reducing the countdown starting
number from 200 to
199 after a long night on the road you
finally find the right turn sending you
in the right direction as you drive
through the night you keep telling
yourself one thing one small phrase over
and over again you hope the words will
eventually give you comfort but deep
down you start to realize just how
hollow they are that it's just a lie we
tell ourselves so we don't have to face
the inevitable but still what choice do
you have but to keep telling yourself
that all is well now check out SCP 3001
red reality and SCP 4511 swine God for
more Nightmares From the world of the CP
Foundation